[Musique]
ce qui sera votée aujourd'hui ce qui
sera présenté aux parlementaires va
changer nos vies pour le mieux et espère
le gouvernement
on verra la réaction des gens mesdames
et messieurs bon après midi si patrice
roy au centre de l'information à
montréal couverture de ce budget fédéral
quatrième budget de bill de bill morneau
dernier budget des libéraux avant la
campagne électorale de l'automne
prochain et donc c'est important
monsieur trudeau espère que son ministre
des finances ne va pas faire un coup sûr
mais un coup de circuit pour faire
oublier l'autre histoire qui roule
encore beaucoup aujourd'hui ottawa snc
lavalin avec moi rené vézina chroniqueur
économique que vous connaissez bien
michel serrault j'ai cru nkr politique
animateurs que vous connaissez bien
aussi daniel thibault neutre amis ottawa
daniel bonsoir bonjour avant mais
bonjour je commence avec vous daniel
parce que je disais oui bien sûr qu'on
attend le budget qui sera déposé en
principe à 16h mais là il ya une joute
politique qui se joue à ottawa les
conservateurs sont furieux veulent que
l'on parle de cette crise de sens et
lavalin sont furieux parce que le comité
de la justice et libérons audi
savez-vous 1mg messieurs c'est terminé
on en a assez entendu
et là on va retarder on va tout faire
pour retarder le dépôt du budget voilà
oui c'est une tactique que les
conservateurs ont commencé à préparer
alors ce que l'on a fait hier soir c'est
qu'on a différents votes on a retardé un
vote qui doivent rallier à soir on l'a
repoussé aujourd'hui des libéraux ne se
sont pas rendu compte de la tactique et
ont pas été en mesure de le déplacer à
l'ordre du jour des travaux aujourd'hui
ce qui fait qu'un seul vote sur une
motion plutôt banal consommant les
travaux d'un comité sur la protection
des baleines et des dauphins dans les
eaux territoriales canadiennes savent
avant lié à 15h55 cet après midi donc
appel au vote à ce moment-là 30 minutes
de cloche est par la suite ce sera ce
sera le vent qui va durer dizaine de
minutes
ce que l'on dit là du côté de
l'opposition officielle c'est ne vous
attendez pas un budget avant 16h45 cet
après midi monsieur trudeau à son
arrivée à la période de questions
aujourd'hui à commenter la tactique
qu'il déplore évidemment on va écouter
ce que c'est bon comme vous dites il ya
beaucoup de trucs dans livres pour pour
pour faire reporter en tout cas faire à
patienter tous les parlementaires parce
qu'il ça pourrait être plus long que 45
minutes
tout ça parce qu'un conservateurs
veulent que l'on parle de quoi de la
sphère snc lavalin or voilà les fêtes
c'est marc 2-2 chose effectivement il ya
d'autres éléments et les gens qui j'ai
parlé aujourd'hui à chez les
conservateurs m'ont dit on vous dira pas
tout mais on a dit des gens sur la place
publique on allait utiliser tous les
outils à notre disposition pour
s'assurer que l'on maintient sur la
sellette la faire et c'est cela valait
tous les outils à leur disposition ça
veut dire par exemple des tactiques
comme celle qui s'apprête à envoyer à la
chambre des communes
il y en ad'autres la personne des
personnes à qui j'ai parlé plus tôt m'a
dit m'a dit qu'on avait déjà étudié un
certain nombre de scénarios
est-ce qu'on va les utiliser aujourd'hui
vous savez comme moi que vraiment donner
ce genre de truc là sa survie recontre
l'utilisateur de tactique alors jusqu'où
on voudra aller on verra tout ça parce
que on est fâché fâché que ce matin le
comité de la justice les libéraux qui
sont majoritaires sur ce que l'italie
ait décidé de mettre un terme aux
travaux parce que distille on entendu
suffisamment témoignage pour se faire
une idée sur ce qui s'est passé dans la
sphère snc-lavalin on peut passer à
autre chose ce n'est pas l'avis des
conservateurs des néo démocrates
rappelez-vous ce chef-d'oeuvre la tête
de monsieur trudeau là dessus et les néo
démocrates réclament une enquête
publique et à la sortie du comité de la
justice monsieur a eu des mots très durs
en point de presse
on peut l'écouter je vais être clair il
s'agit d'un abus
pouvoir c'est une affront à la
démocratie est une attaque contre le
parlement
les canadiens s'attendent à plus de
transparence et en mettant fin à l'
enquête du comité de la justice sur son
propre secondaire de corruption justin
trudeau se moque de chacune entre eux et
daniel on a on a un extrait de la
période de questions qui a eu lieu bien
sûr aujourd'hui pendant que les
journalistes sont en huit lots sont ils
vont sortir dès que le ministre va
ouvrir la bouche pour déposer le budget
donc ce soit 81 45 cents soit cinq
heures on verra mais bref par les
questions ou là vraiment les deux
oppositions et je crois qu'on a un
extrait on vraiment à des tirs groupés
contraire monsieur truc dont on peut
écouter ce groupe et leurs clauses
oui c'est un ami un ancien ministre
libéral de l'époque du scandale des
commandites pour examiner sans scandales
de corruption
puis les libéraux siègent au comité de
la justice en me fait aux travaux du
comité sur cette affaire qu'est ce que
le premier ministre tente de cacher le
comité et usines
depuis cinq semaines des canadiens peut
entendre toutes les perspectives
le commissaire aux convives et continue
d'étudier des dossiers lundi depuis ce
début d'accord des réparations étaient
et demeurent la décision du procureur
général
la triste la personne à qui monsieur
scheer faisait référence en dix ans le
libéral de l'époque du scandale des
commandites la libérale cnd clés l'une
que monsieur trudeau a nommé hier comme
conseillère spéciale dans ce dossier
dans le gouvernement veut obtenir d'elle
et veut utiliser son son passé d'ex
ministre de la justice pour déterminer
si la fonction de ministre de la justice
et de procureur général devrait être
cédée les partis d'opposition ont tourné
tout ça la dérision hier en disant
libéral qui vient enquêter sur les
libéraux bref ça ne fait pas l'unanimité
cette nomination bon et on y arrive dans
un budget déposé par non carmen ce
budget daniel y'a bon retour à un
équilibre budgétaire entre pop pas dans
les prochaines années est ce qu'il y
aura un plan sur trois quatre ans on
verra
j'ai parlé avec j'ai parlé avec des gens
ce matin qu'il disait pour un calendrier
de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire
ne retenez pas votre souffle y aura une
tendance sur une courbe
on va voir où ça s'en va ce sur quoi on
mise aujourd'hui quand on va regarder
les colonnes de chiffres c'est les
revenus qui sont plus élevés que prévu
des dépenses du gouvernement qui sort ce
qu'ils se sont stabilisés le fameux
ratio dette/pib qui souvent utilisé par
monsieur morneau qui va être un avantage
discours du gouvernement aujourd'hui
et puis les mesures qui ont été
présentées ou qui seront présentés nous
laisse-t-on entendre vont cibler entre
autres les milenio avec un programme d'
aide pour l'achat d'une première
propriété en gramme de formation de la
main d'oeuvre pourrait aider les gens à
se recycler dans l'économie du savoir y
aura un incitatif pour l'achat de
véhicules électriques entre autres et
une partie de la compensation
qu'attendent des producteurs laitiers
canadiens qui ont
ont dû essuyer un certain nombre de
compromis là après lecture de l'accord
européen dit brees change du partenariat
transpacifique est d'accord avec les
états unis le mexique pas l'ensemble de
la somme pas cette fameuse compensation
pleine et entière qui avait promis le
gouvernement mais un premier pas dans
cette direction
très bien daniel vous restez là
évidemment je suivre les méandres du
code de conduite des libéraux rené
vézina rebond sur leur bon jour pour
jour permet chelsea où j'ai d'abord
michel c petite analyse de ce qu'est ce
qu'on va vivre ensemble dans les
prochaines heures
c'est s'aider tactique parlementaire
bien sûr pour faire parler de soi puis
l'opposition va pas s'en priver non
l'opposition s'en privent jamais c'est
le grand moment du gouvernement si on
peut le gâche un petit peu on va en
profiter surtout que le budget c'est les
projecteurs sont sur la liste des
finances sur le polémiste qui sont pas
sur l'opposition
on veut savoir ce que dans le budget
imposant ses compositions pense vraiment
alors c'est arrivé des dadas dans
l'histoire des années 90 j'étais atteint
voit déjà je me souvienne marc lalonde
se souvient bien renseignés tout ce que
30 ans qui avait lu un budget au théâtre
la presse plutôt qu'au parlement en
soirée par les conservateurs avaient
fait toutes les tactiques dilatoires
qu'il avait geste très peu de rendez
vous imprévu je n'ai pas de rendez vous
prévue mais j'espère qu'on sera de repos
l'anneau pu et je pense pas d'ailleurs
des règlements de la chambre change un
petit peu plus tôt là aussi très bien
rené vézina
parlons de ce budget de vaud des
attendez on a beaucoup parlé l'assurance
médicaments donc premiers pas d'un
programme national canadien au québec on
sait qu'on a une une assurance
médicaments partiel pour les gens ne
sont pas assurées au privé aide à
l'accès à la propriété formation de la
main d'oeuvre qu'est ce que vous suivez
ou qu'est ce que vous allez regarder
avec attention
je regardais ça soit un budget
particulier patrice puisque c'est la
dernière année du mandat de l'actuel
gouvernement
et c'est habituellement un des budgets
dans ce contexte là sont des budgets qui
sont un peu si vous permettez
l'expression truffé de certaines
friandises et là il risque de ne pas y
en avoir beaucoup
parce que la marge de manoeuvre du
gouvernement est très limité je pense
que la projection du déficit pour
l'année en cours c'est 19 milliards et
demi de dollars
alors on pourra pas les grands et il
faut bien comprendre une chose c'est que
même
si on s'en va vers on va nous daniel le
dit il n'y aura pas de cible précise on
va encore laisser flotter l'idée d'un
retour aux équilibres faut se rappeler
que la vie à peu près unanime des
analystes tant ici qu'à l'international
l'année 2010 ne sera pas l'année la plus
vigoureuse en termes de croissance
économique
donc on prend pas beaucoup misé
là-dessus mais je voudrais qu'on va
surveiller les 3t aujourd'hui et je
présente ainsi le travail que ce
qu'effectivement il ya des mesures qui
vont aller pour la requalification des
travailleurs et aussi pour jouer sur
l'expérience en temps si je peux me
permettre
les mettre en valeur les travailleurs
expérimentés
c'est une expression poli qu'on utilise
maintenant mais c'est vrai que plein de
gens qui pourraient être mises à
contribution
il enrôle les travailleurs plus âgés
plus âgées où il n'avait plus âgés jolie
expérimenté expérimenté web et c'est ça
qu'on dans tout le monde à peu près mais
encore faut-il que le marché du travail
soit en mesure de s'ajuster ça n'est pas
toujours évident il y aura des questions
de transport on en a parlé
subvention peut être un cru pour
l'électrification pour l'achat des
véhicules électriques dès que
l'électrique est pas et véhicules
hybrides ont promis revenir parce que
des fois c'est la porte d'entrée
transport en matière d'infrastructures
parce que les demandes d'un bout à
l'autre du canada
mon le transport en commun qu'il abat
une infrastructure jusqu'ici on en a pas
entendus par des taxes est incapable de
transport d'ailleurs le transport de
données
c'est important aussi à cette question
de l'accès internet ça fait des lunes et
des décennies pratiquement qu'on en
parle et même dans la périphérie des
grandes villes il ya encore des déserts
qu'est-ce qu'on veut nous prévoir la
dent et le dernier thé ce sera une
transition
comment on voit échelonné plus ces
programmes patrice point internet
on évoque la date de 2030
c'est comme c'est la moitié d'une
génération son onze il peut y avoir bien
d'autres révolutions technologiques
depuis
alors oui à ces grands éléments là il
faudra voir si on y va avec des mesures
globales ou des cibles savait qu'elle
avait eu les élections on aime bien
cibler des groupes alors faudra voir
souvent laissées dans les détails
s'avère en bas de la page 238 qu'on a
l'élément qui fait surtout elle pourra
fouler l'accès à la propriété on a
beaucoup parlé des jeunes ont vu
les 35 ans et moins et même les 26
mètres c'est quand même moi 25 ans et
moins les millénium pour l'accès à la
propriété ça ça sonne déclenché beaucoup
aussi
dans loin sous le prix des maisons est
elle les jeunes ne peuvent pas acheter
alors on verra ces détails là le déficit
le déficit ça va être un débat sa ration
débat les conservateurs ont décidé que
c'était leur cheval de bataille
aussi michel c oui parce que le
gouvernement souvenez-vous a pris les
commandes avec un déficit zéro et qui à
ce moment là et quand le sucre et l'eau
est arrivé a dit nous allons avoir un
plan de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire
pour la dernière année dans notre mandat
donc cette année théoriquement on aurait
dû être à zéro
là on ne l'est pas évidemment et les
conservateurs vont utiliser ça en dix
ans et ils n'ont pas complètement tort
les cycles économiques étant ce qu'ils
sont
on répare le toit de la maison quand il
fait beau pas quand il pleut et là après
disait de croissance
on peut s'attendre d'un ralentissement
économique personne va utiliser l'autre
morère la récession mais c'est pas
impossible et on va dire et évidemment
s'il avait des ralentissements
économiques ou à la récession le déficit
automatiquement augmente très rapidement
et davantage dans leur c'est là dessus
que les conservateurs alors voilà et
monsieur trudeau va tabler sur le petit
livre grave moyens livre qu'il entier
mais vous venez de le voir il a fait son
entrée
je disais d'entrée de jeu il a besoin de
son minet et finale chez morneau tape un
coup de circuit aujourd'hui daniel
thibault parce qu'un coup sûr ce sera
pas suffisant ce budget-là doit changer
comme on dit en mauvais français la
conversation ottawa et doivent reprendre
le dessus sur l'histoire snc lavalin
c'est là dessus qu'on mise côté libéral
effectivement on veut que ce budget-là
devienne la pierre le point tournant là
ce moment ci est que ce soit ce que ce
soit l'élément dont on parle
à partir de maintenant jusqu'à la
prochaine campagne électorale
vous avez bien compris que les
conservateurs les démocrates souhaitent
le contraire alors à quel point est-ce
que les éléments qui sont contenues dans
un petit bouquin que monsieur morneau et
monsieur monsieur mono et trudeau avait
entre les mains il ya quelques minutes à
quel point est-ce que ça va vraiment
permettre au gouvernement de recentrer
le message de rediriger les choses
ailleurs ont mis sur le fait que votre
temps les travaux du comité
du côté de la justice ont terminé qu'on
peut peut-être mettre de l'avant à ces
idées là regardez bien ce qui va se
passer au cours des prochains jours l'on
n'est même pas encore on connaît pas le
contenu du budget je peux déjà vous dire
que demain la semaine prochaine il va y
avoir des ministres des députés sur la
route pour en parler en faire la
promotion
on veut que ça change le ton on veut
renverser la vapeur et on veut que ce
soit ce document là qui donne le ton à
la campagne sans lui on veut des
attentes on va faire une tournée avec
nos collègues journalistes
d'abord faire goûter le premier du club
en nommant allons-y alexandra duval vous
êtes à saint georges
catherine routier à montréal valérie
gamache à vancouver alors il ya des
gens qui attendent vraiment qu'ils
soient 4 en 4 heures 10 4 heures 30 on
verra quelle heure ils prêts à déposer
le budget pour voir si leurs voeux
seront exaucés alexandra duval parmi ces
gens là il ya les producteurs laitiers
ils l'attendent de pied ferme ce budget
aujourd'hui patrice on comprend qu'ils
auront droit à des compensations mais de
quel ordre
et est ce que ce sera suffisant pour eux
et pour les calmer même je vous dirais
parce que eux ils estiment qu'ils ont
perdu beaucoup d'argent au cours des
dernières années notamment depuis la
signature de ce traité transpacifique
des autres dont daniel nous parlait
voyez des images on s'est rendu à la
firme du hibou monsieur l'abbé et
producteurs les cils lui depuis une
vingtaine d'années et nous raconter et
qu'il perd en moyenne ces temps-ci 120
dollars bruts par jour alors faites le
calcul sur une année c'est beaucoup il a
même dû réduire ses effectifs
alors pour lui bien sûr il sera à
l'écouté de ce budget et c'est pas
compliqué ça passe ou ça casse carrément
avec le gouvernement trudeau
on les écoute nous ont promis une
compensation pleine et entière
il ya promis de protéger la gestion de
l'offre puis à chaque promesse il y ait
jamais connu donc on va essayer d'autres
choses on se trouve à l'alternative but
et on va voir ce qu'il ya dans
l'opposition si ça peut être mieux et
puis c'est sûr et certain climat qui
veut rétablir avec les voix de confiance
son budget aujourd'hui très important
sinon on investir au pot dans le domaine
des ti piscine on attend sur la
prochaine campagne électorale dans tous
les coins et là ça sera pas jojo donc on
croit on croit qui aura vraiment une
annonce dans ce budget là peut-être pas
l'entièreté de la somme là mais en tout
cas quelque chose pour apaiser un peu
ces gens là qui attendent pilon d'aussi
important on vient d'en parler c'est le
financement du transport en commun qui à
québec ça sonne une cloche
pourquoi parce qu'à québec ça rime avec
tramway il ya tout ce financement du
tramway laqué
très attendue cette semaine avec ces
deux budgets fédéral provincial et
fédéral et provincial qui ont promis de
l'argent mais yann partie là de ce vaste
projet de 3 milliards de dollars c'est à
dire 1 800 millions qui fait l'objet
d'une chicane entre québec et ottawa
je voudrais que ce pc administratif mais
bon tout cela n'est pas encore réglé et
le maire régis labeaume est carrément
exaspéré il ne s'est pas gêné pour
passer son message
écoutons le il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'argent sur la table le transport
collectif il y en a à québec il y en à
ottawa mais là on se chicane 1 pour
savoir si mon père est plus fort que le
fier parce que c'est sûr qu'une chienne
provincie fédérale-provinciale ça peut
être payé payant politiquement mais
c'est pas payer un politiquement pour la
ville de québec puis on en a marre
essai de budget donc qu'ils sont très
attendus pour la ville de québec et ce
vaste projet de plus de 3 milliards de
da ben voilà au site assez clair
monsieur le maire est assez clair merci
alexandre à catherine gauthier à
montréal beaucoup d'attentes également
dans la grande région de montréal pour
des projets de transport en commun
si québec veut son tramway et patrice et
bien montréal et surtout valérie plante
elle veut sa ligne rose line gross qui
porte très très bien vu pour le moment
du côté du gouvernement le go donc on
souhaite peut-être que le fédéral
investisse davantage entre autres dans
le transport en commun ce qu'ont fait
les grandes villes du pays
patrice donc entre autres montréal
vancouver et toronto
c'est qu'on demande un financement qui
serait permanent pour les projets de
transport en commun pourquoi parce qu'on
est en mode rattrapage depuis plusieurs
années et ce que dit la mairesse de mont
assez on voudrait avoir le financement à
hauteur de nos ambitions
vancouver veut prolonger son skytrain
toronto veut faire une voie
contournement entre autres dans l'est de
la ville reine donc il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de projets y compris à montréal
écoutez là dessus le porte à rolle de
trajectoire québec pour montréal
énormément besoin et on passe l'oeil à
la rame qui va se faire mais qu'on pense
entre autres au niveau de compléter le
réseau de métro de la ligne bleue
évidemment qui a pas encore été vraiment
confirmé il y aller c'est sûr il peut y
avoir d extension de la ligne jaune sur
la rive sud de la ligne orange au moins
jusqu'à bois-francs sinon à l'avant et
puis ya éventuellement peut-être un
projet de l'île rousse et catherine ça
déjà été télégraphié le y aura dans ce
budget morneau quatrième budget morneau
de l'argent supplémentaire pour les
acheteurs de voitures électriques
voitures électriques et possiblement pas
pour les voitures hybrides patrie
c'était une bonne différence
ce que disait entre autres monsieur
pépin trajectoire québec c'est beau
c'est bien parce qu'effectivement ça va
faire qu'on va peut-être diminuer les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
contre ça va pas diminuer les problèmes
de circulation automobile qui sont
grandissants dans les grandes villes
alors on aurait plutôt souhaité qu'on
revienne un incitatif pour les gens qui
achètent justement une carte mensuelle
pour le transport en commun
ça c'est pas dans les cartons à ce qu'on
nous dit il faudra voir bien sûr dans ce
budget là mais en tout cas assurément
5000 $ semble-t-il pour l'achat de
véhicules électriques
très bien merci catherine on sera à
vancouver
parce que vancouver symbolise un
problème qui équipent en canadiens
l'accès à la propriété pour les jeunes
familles l'on parle des milléniaux entre
autres 25 ans et moins
chez vous c'est hallucinant pas ça coûte
tellement cher on attend des choses
concrètes dans ce budget parce que une
maison unifamiliale à vancouver se vend
en moyenne 1,4 million de dollars selon
les dernières données de la chambre
immobilière
ça veut dire que ménage donc qui a un
revenu de 150 mille dollars n'a pas les
moyens de s'acheter une maison à
vancouver on a rencontré d'ailleurs une
famille qui a acheté un domicile un
duplex il ya cinq ans ce qui ne serait
plus capable aujourd'hui de s'offrir la
même résidence est vraiment notre tout
mis en place pour tenter de rentabiliser
cet investissement là c'est à dire que
on a une garderie en milieu familial
on profite également du tourisme on loue
une chambre la bière orbi nbi vraiment
on tente le plus possible de faire en
sorte d'optimiser est cet investissement
là ce sont des familles qui également
voir toute facture un peu impromptue
ébranlé le budget c'est le cas entre
autres par exemple lorsqu'une facture de
médicaments arrivent vraiment ça
déstabilise le revenu est familière on
voit d'un bon oeil l'arrivée d'un régime
universel d'assurance médicaments
voulant que le coût élevé de la vie à
vancouver fait en sorte que ça rend le
recrutement données d'oeuvres difficile
du fait on vit à vancouver mais parfois
on a l'impression d'avoir de la
difficulté à voir les services bien
simple comme en éducation ou encore en
santé on cherche des aussi des services
de garde en charge des enseignants pour
les écoles on cherche
les services ce qui est les familles ici
autour de la communauté si les ont six
personnes n'ont pas accès au logement
ça veut dire qu'il ya moins de
spécialistes des professionnels qu'on
peut ceux qui on peut compter
donc ça rend la vie difficile pour nous
mais ça aussi affecte tout le monde de
la communauté autour de nous
ils valérie depuis plusieurs années lors
de chaque campagne électorale lors de
chaque dépôt de budget on en parle si tu
c'était un dossier fort important pour
des millions de canadiens accès à
internet haute vitesse est pas réglé
dans bien des cas il ya 6 millions de
canadiens qui n'ont toujours pas accès à
internet haute vitesse c'est le cas dans
des communautés éloignées on dit
d'ailleurs que dans l est et milieux
ruraux l'oeil à un canadien sur cinq
qu'une mauvaise connexion internet alors
on vous réglez ça parce que ça vraiment
adn conséquences d'un point de vue
économique mais aussi d'un point de vue
social que l'on pense à des gens qui
pourraient avoir des services de
télémédecine ou encore tout simplement
des alertes d'urgence qui sont
accessibles grâce à internet haute
vitesse et ses communautés l'actuel
demande de son producteur
très bien merci beaucoup valérie ça
donne bonne idée là de toutes les
attentes
aujourd'hui merci alors voilà je vous
rappelle mesdames et messieurs qu'en
principe dépôt du budget à 16 heures on
vous expliquait daniel vous l'expliquer
tout à l'heure que les conservateurs ont
utilisé toutes sortes de procédés
parlementaire pour retarder le dépôt du
budget mais il pourrait quand même à 16h
avoir une permission de donner les
informations levée dont du huis clos
budgétaire des nantis bouge est là oui
absolument
donc on en est où écoutez à l'heure
actuelle n'y a pas d'éducation et je
veux juste de contrer vérifier qu'un
collègue qui était tout près du foyer il
n'y a pas d'indication à l'effet clés
des conservateurs aient décidé changer
d'idée le calendrier qu'on nous qu'on
nous expose c'est toujours la fille de
fameux le fameux vote sur cette motion
un sénatoriale qui aurait lieu là on
éteint
et en seconde lecture mon projet doit
ses 92 sa journée dans la période qui
est toujours ça c'était prévu les
conservateurs n'auraient pas l'intention
de reculer je vais aller aux nouvelles
pour m'assurer les nouvelles envisagées
par nokia apparemment par les pompiers
tout de suite ont écouté
copie du discours du budget qui ont été
distribués vous l'avez vu à la chambre
des communes ce n'est pas clair pour moi
6 à 4 heures ou en tout cas quatre
heures et des poussières on pourra
donner avec nos collègues
gérald fillion madeleine blais murray
qui sont dans le huit clos son époque
ainsi on pourra donner tous les détails
une formation qu'on pourra le faire on
le fera avec un plaisir le ministère de
répliquer aux manoeuvres daniel si je
comprends bien des consommateurs en
disant bon bien allons-y ce qu'on croit
comprendre de la motion qui a été
déposée et la j'écoute attentivement de
ce que de ce que monsieur morneau a dit
en chambre
c'est que il a déposé les documents il
allait fournir une copie du document
budgétaire à tous les parlementaires et
qu'il allait lever le huit lots à la
fermeture des marchés
à 16 heures c'est donc dire que
techniquement on pourrait être en mesure
de vous parler du contenu du budget
avant qu'il ait le loisir de prononcer
son discours à la chambre des communes
puisqu'ils laurent puisque les marchés
escomptaient seront fermés puisque il
leur a également fourni que puis du
budget à tous les membres a tous les
atouts les députés de la chambre des
sumos nouvelles sur une bonne mais ça
veut dire que c'est une façon de
contrecarrer la tactique des tactiques
conservatrice c'est ce que j'en
comprends pour l'instant voyons voir
comment ça va se dérouler au cours des
prochaines secondes
c'est très bien daniel veut rester avec
nous mais l'avion va faire une courte
pause on revient ensuite avec tous les
détails de ce quatrième budget de bill
morneau a tout de suite
[Musique]
jma tard retrouvé des montants très
précis dans le budget de la politique
concernant la ligne bleue 4 milliards le
tramway plaider aux structures inquiète
1,2 milliard il n'y a jamais eu autant
d'argent sur la table et on se chicane
pour savoir si mon père est plus fort
galtier le fédéral a fait des belles
annonces mais malheureusement chaque
fois l'échec est pas normal
demain on s'attend aussi à voir les
compensations pour les producteurs
laitiers pour souhaiterait qu'ils
compensent ces personnes pensent que le
budget va distraire les canadiens les
conservateurs ne vont pas rester les
bras croisés
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonjour bonne fin
d'après midi vous voyez des images du
premier mineur
justin trudeau et de son minet et
finance bill morneau il ya quelques
secondes à ottawa avec le budget entre
les mains monsieur trudeau qui souhaite
de tout coeur que ce budget puisse
changer le climat au parlement à ottawa
où vous savez qui depuis quatre semaines
on parle de snc lavalin
il ya des choses dans ce budget là qui
vont vous toucher directement achat d
autos électriques assurant ce médicament
accès à la propriété un budget c'est un
texte important démocratie le
gouvernement s'exprime et change les
règles du jeu avec moi
gérald fillion madeleine blé mort et
vous sortez michels et augé rené vézina
bonsoir bonjour à vous trois bonjour
majeur je commence avec vous vous sortez
tout juste de ce huis clos qui sera levé
ou qui est déjà levé il ya quelques
secondes c'est un budget politiquement
important pays économiquement mais on
verra s'il ya beaucoup de choses dedans
mais c'est politiquement important parce
que c'est le tout dernier budget avant
les prochaines élections d'octobre
prochain donc on peut se poser la
question est-ce que c'est oui ou non un
budget électoraliste
je vais y aller finalement en mythe est
en partie cet électorat liste partielle
quand même dans ce budget la démesure de
5 milliards de dollars pour l'année qui
s'entame on veut entre autres faciliter
la vie
des aînés dans le besoin on veut aussi
faciliter l'achat d'une première
propriété et on veut mettre le jeter les
bases d'un programme d'assurance
médicaments donc vous voyez on est
clairement dans les plates-bandes vue
parti néo-démocrate beaucoup moins dans
celle du parti conservateur parce que la
toute première ligne que le parti
conservateur va vérifier c'est celle du
déficit et il ya effectivement encore
cette année un déficit et pas de plan de
retour à l'équilibré budgétaire un
déficit de cette année qui frôle les 20
milliards de dollars ce qui était à peu
près ce qui était prévu lors de la
dernière mise à jour économique de
l'automne dernier donc c'est aussi un
électoralistes en partie parce que il ya
certaines mesures qui ne sont pas
clairement définies donc ça va permettre
au gouvernement de faire toute sorte d'
annonce d'ici octobre prochain pour
détailler les programmes qui ont été
annoncés mais quand on parle d'
électoraliste on dit aussi parfois que
c'est clientéliste dirais que c'est pas
tout à fait le cas
on n'est pas en train de saupoudrer des
millions par ci par là à gauche à droite
pour des petites clientes l on est quand
même dans des grands programmes dont
mais allons-y donne les fins de non les
chefs gerald bonsoir à vous bonsoir en
fin d'après-midi alors vous sortez
toujours on a vu un premier tableau
général on peut peut-être le revoir ça
c'est les grandes les paramètres
dépenses revenu ce comme un budget comme
chez nous revenu à holy pense réserve
égales - presque 20 milliards de
difficile c'est ça alors revenu de 339
milliards de dollars je ne m'entends pas
malheureusement je fais juste le signal
et dépenses de 3 155 milliards et la
réserve parce qu'on continue de
maintenir une réserve budgétaire de 3
milliards donc le déficit est un peu
plus important que ce qui avait été
entendue 19 milliards 800 millions
on maintient on assume le déficit
budgétaire donc on maintient cela est
dans ce qui est annoncé il ya quatre
grandes mesures je vous dirai quand on
regarde les faits saillants
on vient bonifier l'aide à l'achat d'une
première propriété
c'est ce qu'on avait mentionné
les derniers jours ça avait été ébruitée
bonification de l'aide à l'achat d'une
première propriété qui dit je vais vous
l'expliquer l'assassin revient que 10 à
la formation pour les personnes qui sont
âgés de 25 à 64 ans qui sont des
travailleurs
vous pourrez amasser de l'argent 250 $
par année
et si vous en avez besoin pour une
formation vous ignorez droit il ya des
mesures pour les aînés notamment une
bonification de l'exemption du revenu de
travail qui va faire en sorte que vous
allez pouvoir garder votre supplément de
revenu garanti davantage d'argent du
supplément de revenu garanti et nous
l'annoncions hier soir patrice les
producteurs laitiers les producteurs
sous gestion de l'offre le lait la
volaille également le total du soutien
pour ce qui est des compensations sur
les accords commerciaux avec lui les
pertes de marché et le soutien également
avec la valeur des quotas qu'on veut
garantir s'élève à 3 milliards 650
millions très bien donc les faits
saillants sont faits revenons à l'achat
d'une première maison pour les jeunes
enfin pau l'achat d'une première maison
sur une des mesures phare je comprends
dire exactement et vous dites pour les
jeunes parce que l'objectif c'est
justement de faire en sorte que les
millions en quelque sorte aient accès à
une propriété dans un monde où ça coûte
de plus en plus cher s'acheter une
maison
le rap le régime d'accès à la propriété
de 25000 présentement il va passer à 35
mille dollars que vous pouvez emprunter
de votre reér pour investir dans une
mise de fonds pour acheter une première
propriété est une nouveauté c'est un
nouveau programme qui est annoncé
aujourd'hui la schl va participer pour
une part de 5 à 10 % de votre hypothèque
autrement dit vous nous votre
remboursement hypothécaire sera abaissé
de cette somme là donc par exemple sur
une maison de 400 mille la schl peut
mettre quarante mille dollars que vous
allez rembourser quand vous allez vendre
votre maison est ce que sa vie est
intéressant ça vient surtout réduire le
paiement hypothécaire que vous avez à
faire
ça peut paraître quand même ça fait des
bonnes sommes plusieurs centaines de
dollars pour pour les gens qui ont accès
à ça donc
premier point premières mesures
structurantes c'est celle-là l'achat
d'une première propriété puis là vous
avez un exemple
voyez l'hypothèque assuré 340000 la schl
40000 et le coût financier mensuel
s'élève à 1745 odieux de 1973 dollars je
pense que ça va plaire à des gens
justement qui veut s'acheter première
propriété le qui nous ça va faire une
différence entre l'achat et et être
incapable d'acheter en fait pour
plusieurs personnes
absolument absolument c'est non et donc
il y à il ya quand même un plafond donc
on va pas acheter des maisons à 1
million à vancouver avec cela c'est très
important de le dire mais on peut
acheter une maison de 400 à 500 mille
dollars avec s'appuie avoir un soutien
la deuxième mesure très structurante
c'est la formation
un crédit pour la formation de 250 $ par
année pour les personnes de 25 à 64 ans
vous pouvez accumuler comme ça jusqu'à
5000 $ et si vous gagnez la jusqu'à 150
milles par année donc dès 2020 c'est de
l'argent qui est là qui est disponible
on vous l'envoie pas la maison mais il
est disponible pour vous à un moment
donné vous avez besoin de former
retourner au collège à l'université pour
suivre une formation
il ya également la possibilité d'avoir
un soutien de quatre semaines à 55 % de
votre revenu moyen pour de la formation
également ça c'est la mesure formation
la mesure pour les aînés c'est sur le
supplément de revenu garanti en ce
moment pour encourager les aînés à
rester au travail l'extension complète
ou partielle sur le revenu d'emploi ou
de travail ça va jusqu'à 15000 parce que
souvent vous allez gagner de l'argent
vous avez une petit job à temps partiel
vous gagner un peu d'argent ça vient
amputer votre supplément de revenu
garanti
là on dit que jusqu'à 15000 c'est une
extension complète ou partielle là il ya
toutes sortes de détails là dessus mais
ça vous permettre de toucher davantage
d'argent pour ce qui est du supplément
de revenu garanti et l'autre mesure
fondamentale importante aujourd'hui
c'est pour les producteurs sous gestion
de l'offre
alors il ya deux milliards cent
cinquante millions disponibles pour
compenser les coûts qui y sont associés
perte de revenus avec les accords
commerciaux qui ont été signés avec
l'europe et avec le partenariat
transpacifique ayant 1 milliard 500
millions également qui est prévu comme
programme de la garantie de garantie de
la valeur des quotas parce que on sait
que la gestion de l'offre est souvent
malmené par les accords commerciaux
là on dit on met de l'argent pour
garantir les quotas très bien gérald
tout de suite madeleine on revienne
secondes sur la question du déficit est
ce que c'est un risque au plan politique
parce qu'on dit qu'il va d'un sis au
cours des trois prochaines années mais
on ne vient pas d'un programme pour
l'éliminer absolument pas y a pas de
date de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire
on a posé la question en point de presse
à l'intérieur du huis clos au ministre
bill morneau ont eu à demander à quand
le retour à l'équilibré budgétaire et
cette question là il refuse d'y répondre
alors on est clairement avec le dépôt de
ce budget là dans la catégorie des
promesses rompues parce que lors des
dernières élections le gouvernement
avait fait le pari des déficits mais en
disant on retournera à l'équilibré
budgétaire dans un premier mandat donc
en 2019
on atteint 2019 et maintenant on n'a pas
de date de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire et gérald le disais c'est
pleinement assumé le gouvernement fait
maintenant le pari que il vaut mieux
injecter de l'oxygène dans les jambes
dans les familles plutôt que de penser à
écrire un budget à l'encré noire on
pense que c'est plus payant
politiquement finalement d'agir de la
sorte et que l'économie s'en porte mieux
on montre preuves à l'appui le taux de
chômage qui ont aidé à son plus bas
niveau en 40 ans les centaines de
milliers d'emplois créés depuis le début
du mandat
mais ça va devenir une ligne de
démarcation avec les consommateurs les
conservateurs ce aussi sûr et certain
de toute façon même s'il y avait eu un
plan de retour à l'équilibré budgétaire
même si on avait dit dans dix ans dans
cinq ans on aura le retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire les conservateurs auraient
attaqué les libéraux de toute façon en
disant vous l'avez rompu votre promesse
on ne vous croit plus mais les libéraux
pourront demander aux conservateurs que
couperez vous certain budget la queue
court et vous suivent exactement est là
parce qu'on dit chili et on ne veut pas
montrer qu'on est en position de
faiblesse aux positions de défense en
défensive on montre même une certaine je
dirais offensive en disant comme vous le
dites patrice et on dit aux
conservateurs où justement où allez vous
coupez donc ça devient une position d'
attaque d'une certaine façon de part et
d'autre très bien pour nous j'imagine
beaucoup souligné le ministre a dû le
faire au der on aura des extraits d'une
entrevue général de fait avec le milieu
des finances on imagine beaucoup
souligné le ratio pib et dette là qui
réduit quand même qu'ils continuent sur
une pente descendante c'est maintenant
le nouvel ancrage en du parti libéral
c'est de dire on est des gens
fiscalement prudent parce que voyez-vous
ce ratio dette/pib qui te peu plus
compliqué à comprendre que le simple mot
décès mais qui est quand même c'est ce à
cette taille du déficit par rapport à
l'économie au complet on est sur une
pente descendante donc l'économie se
porte bien évidemment s'il ya un
ralentissement économique est ce qu'on
va être en mesure d'investir davantage
on verra et on voit aussi qu'on essaie
quand même de maintenir un déficit qui
est sous la barre des 20 milliards de
dollars comme si elle est logique léger
qu'on veut pas dépasser un nom avec
d'autres mesures gérald on a beaucoup
parlé depuis quelques jours de cette
assurance médicaments
on veut il ya un processus pour mettre
en place ce genre d'assurance au canada
ce sera une promesse un engagement
électoral on présume est ce qu'il ya des
détails mais on commence à avoir des
détails mais il faudrait être patient
avant de voir le coût des médicaments
baissé au canada mais on s'en va vers ça
avec ce qui est annoncé aujourd'hui on
parle d'une agence canadienne des
médicaments
pour l'instant on parle d'un bureau de
transition il ya de l'argent qui a été
dans ce budget préparé présenté pour
faire la transition
les médicaments coûtent 20% de plus au
canada que dans d'autres économies
avancées et ça coûte presque 34
milliards de dollars en médicaments
l'objectif avec l' agence canadienne des
médicaments
c'est de négocier l'achat de médicaments
pour le compte des différentes
assurances qui existent les différents
régimes d'assurance au canada
pour baissé d'à peu près 3 milliards de
dollars les coûts des médicaments
on va créer aussi un formulaire
nationale de médicaments sur ordonnance
donc ça s'en vient soyez patient 2022
2023 pour la suite des choses et quand
je vous parle d'autres mesures la
madeleine mentionnait qui avait pas de
saupoudrage
mais on a quand même cibler certaines
choses en tentant d'aller peser sur des
bons boutons voiture électrique 100 %
électrique ni un incitatif qui existe au
québec de 8000 dollars vous pourrez
ajouter 5000 $ qui vient du gouvernement
fédéral en incitatifs pour les voitures
électriques il ya aussi des instits
hâtive pour les entreprises pour qu'ils
viennent déduire de façon immédiate
l'achat d'un véhicule électrique
l'internet haute vitesse
j'ai l'impression que ça fait 15 ans
qu'on annonce à patrice c'est encore là
mais ça a l'air que c'est vrai cette
fois 6 5 milliards à 6 milliards d'ici
2030 pour qu'en 2030 100 % des canadiens
soient branchés à la haute vitesse et
bien sûr le soutien aux autochtones
notamment l'eau potable
presque 5 milliards de dollars
supplémentaires sur cinq ans à ce qui
avait déjà été annoncée dans le dernier
budget pour les autochtones on va parler
de la dette dans une seconde mais parlez
moi de la frontière je crois qu'on a
annoncé de l'argent pour tenter de
calmer ou apaiser cette histoire avec
les immigrants qui entre de façon
illégale au canada on met de l'argent
là-dedans aussi le une réponse au
discours des conservateurs également
c'est à dire qu'il ya pas de
compensation
la compensation continue à être
négociées pour ce qui est de la
compensation aux provinces pour les
réfugiés mais je laisse madeleine
répondre là dessus très bien madeleine
oui on allonge l'argent pourquoi
sécuriser la frontière
j'ai justement il ya de l'argent qui est
qui prévu pour la frontière mais j'ai
pas le montant sous les yeux en ce
moment mais effectivement gérad l'avait
mentionné 1,5 milliard ce que j'ai fait
je fais un papier s'est passé le 7
milliards alors si on se ranger la
question mais vous le saviez
alors si c'est un des secteurs où on
sent qu'il va peut-être y avoir un débat
électoral parce qu'on sent qu'il y a de
l'inquiétude sur tous ces migrants qui
passe à la frontière de faveur entre
autres irrégulière alors le gouvernement
veut se montrer proactif sur ce domaine
l'homme effectivement y avait des
négociations avec québec pour rembourser
une et par des dépenses supplémentaires
engendrées pour la province de québec
avec tous immigrants qui avait traversé
notamment au chemin loxam là il n'y a
pas d'argent pas d'argent encore nous
existons parce que ces négociations là
elles ont toujours cours
c'est que toute cette question de tout
des projets de loi gouvernemental au
québec et avec ottawa on ne s'entend pas
encore donc il reste encore beaucoup de
négociations avoir à ce chapitre alors
très bien gérald la dette oui je le
dirai madeleine un peu vous ai fait un
tableau
voilà mais c'est important la dette
parce que ça vient appuyer je vous dirai
tout la logique des libéraux de
maintenir le gouvernement dans des
déficits malgré les déficits la dette
baisse la dette baisse pont dollars
c'est clair 705 milliards de dollars
mais puisque la croissance économique
est plus importante que la hausse de
l'endettement
on va passer en 2010 7,18 de 31 3% de la
valeur des dettes par rapport à
l'économie au pib à 32 7 % dans le
budget présent à 28 6% selon la
projection pour 2023 24 donc le
gouvernement dit tant et aussi longtemps
qu'on investit dans l'économie qu'on
voit la dette baisser on peut faire des
déficits
en 2015 on disait que l' équilibre
budgétaire c'était le budget
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on oublie ça
complètement on maintient les déficits
et on n'a toujours pas de cible de
retour à l'équilibré budgétaire en 2023
24 on prévoit toujours un déficit de
près de 10 milliards de dollars
très bien on aura les réactions qui
seront recueillies mais on vient de voir
d'abord réaction des provinces réaction
des producteurs laitiers est ce que ça
sera jugé suffisant réaction du milieu
des affaires
vous avez pu parler à des gens dans le
huis-clos premier en premier première
impression générale et madeleine jerad
entreprise je vous dirais on s'attendait
peut-être un petit peu plus du côté des
entreprises on est un petit peu déçue
mais en même temps dans l'énoncé
économique du 21 novembre il y en avait
sur la déduction la mort de
l'amortissement accéléré
donc il y avait déjà des mesures pour
les entreprises de ce côté là les
producteurs laitiers vont probablement
dire que ça prend du temps a annoncé oui
on met les sommes
mais on voudrait on aurait souhaité
aujourd'hui que les sommes soient versés
directement ciblé directement et qu'on
est davantage d'informations sur le
soutien qui sera accordée je vous
rappelle qu'on a le partenariat
transpacifique l'accord avec l'europe
on a l'accord avec les états unis et le
mexique qui s'en vient c'est presque 10%
d'ouverture pour les producteurs
laitiers du marché des produits laitiers
les producteurs ont besoin d'un soutien
affirme qu'ils ont besoin d'un soutien
mais là on a des chiffres alors on a on
a un peu plus de deux milliards de
dollars pour compenser puis on vient
ajouter 1 milliard 500 millions pour
pour s'assurer de la valeur des quotas
sous gestion de l'offre dans le futur
pas de la droite le savez le cas avec
plusieurs aspects qui sont dans ce
budget là on n'a pas les détaillants
voyez vous pour les producteurs laitiers
c'est vrai alors au lieu peut-être une
certaine on va peut-être être rassuré en
partie de voir un chiffre clair et net
écrit mais en même temps comment ça va
s'articuler ce programme là il y avait
eu de grandes déceptions
après les compensations offertes pour
l'accord avec l'europe
lorsqu'on avait dit bon il faut investir
c'est pas nécessairement recevoir de
l'argent dans ses poches pour compenser
les fromages fins d'europe qui rentrent
sur le marché canadien
comment tout ça va s'articuler il n'y a
pas d'argent encore de prévu pour la
lena 2.0 qui évidemment n'est pas
pratique
les trois pays donc il reste beaucoup
d'incertitudes même si on a un chiffre
pour ce qui est de l'assurance
médicaments
on parlait tout à l'heure des
plates-bandes néo-démocrate les sociétés
la prochaine frontière de l'assurance
maladie
selon le npd ça fait 20 ans qu'ils le
promettent donc là on va avoir
l'impression qu'on on est en train de
jouer dans leur territoire mais en même
temps de folie d'état et on est en train
d'élaborer tranquillement quelque chose
donc peut-être que c'est prometteur mais
il ya encore beaucoup beaucoup de chemin
à faire avant de comprendre exactement
comment tous à bord qui va s'articuler
seles cus et les d'autres détails
arriveront dans la plateforme électorale
à l'automne manifestement on chérit le
détail et quelle sera la marge de
manoeuvre pour en promettre plus ça
reste à voir aussi parce que là on est à
un déficit d'environ 20 milliards là si
on avait su on arrondit on pourra pas
nécessairement annoncé beaucoup plus de
nouvelles mesures coûteuses sans peut
être agacé l'électorat qui est plus
sensible à ces questions de budgétaire
mais en même temps c'est pas grand chose
le déficit à 15 20 milliards c'est en
bas de 1% du produit intérieur brut aux
états unis on est à 4 5% du produit
intérieur brut en europe on a du mal à
atteindre la cible qui est paul déficit
zéro qui est d'atteindre un déficit qui
représente 3% du produit intérieur brut
donc on est dans une marge mais les
libéraux on voit surtout le message
qu'ils assument pleinement le fait qu'on
est en déficit qu'on va pas au déficit
zéro parce que s'ils voulaient atteindre
le déficit zéro
ce serait possible nous sommes en
croissance économique année après année
il serait possible d'aller là ça c'est
une chose
et l'autre chose d'assez les éléments
plus fondamentaux qui sont quand même
annoncé aujourd'hui et qui répondent à
des besoins de l'économie patrice et du
marché du travail
quand on parle de formation à long terme
la le monde du travail change vite il ya
des emplois qui vont disparaître
on est dans l'automatisation des
fonctions faut améliorer notre
productivité
c'est genre de chose qui peut aider nos
jeunes jouent sur l'information
gérald données - davantage le clip
concrètement ça fera une différence que
ces crédits
que ces programmes pour la formation oui
ça va faire une différence parce que
c'est en trois volets en quelque sorte
le crédit pour la formation fait en
sorte que vous travaillez vous entrez
sur le marché du travail vous arrivez à
40 ans on vous dit vous avez besoin de
formation supplémentaires où va votre
compétence est un peu désuète par
rapport à la suite des choses qu'est ce
que vous faites et compte tenu que
l'économie s'accélère s'automatise
davantage il va falloir suivre la
formation dont vous aurez un compte dans
lequel vous aurez de l'argent 250 par
année jusqu'à 5000 $ qui est cumulatif
et vous pourrez donc payer la moitié de
votre formation collégiale
professionnels ou universitaires
ça va obliger aussi les institutions
d'enseignement à être beaucoup plus
branché sur les besoins du marché du
travail et à faire des offres justement
intéressante pour les personnes qui ont
besoin d'informations supplémentaires
on travaille avec l'assurance emploi
également le 4 semaines qui est
disponible à 5% à 5 ans m
55 % du revenu moyen du travailleur pour
faire en sorte que le travailleur puisse
aller prendre congé et puisse aller
travailler puis les pme sont compensées
puisque les pme pour en voir une baisse
de cotisations à l'assurance emploi puis
à des congés également qui seront
disponibles pour les travailleurs qui
doivent suivre des formations
donc c'est un nouveau programme des
détails s'ajouteront ça s'inspire de ce
qu'on a vu à singapour singapour ses 500
$ par année le comte formation et si on
se contente plutôt de 250 dollars mais
c'est de mettre de l'argent de côté pour
vous encourager à vous former à l'efo
avoir une économie plus productive et
plus spécialisés pour suivre le
mouvement et les mouvements économiques
très bien joué a posé la question mais
celle ci à rené vézina dans une seconde
mais madeleine est ce que mes madeleines
mais madeleine est ce que selon vous
messieurs j'arrive à vous dans une
seconde selon vous est-ce que la teneur
de ce budget morneau le quatrième et va
faire en sorte qu'on va changer
le climat à ottawa c'est une très bonne
question parce que généralement un
budget préélectoral comme sas analyse
dans un contexte justement de est ce qu
est ce que ça va faire la cote dont en
vue des prochaines élections
mais là c'est plutôt est ce que ça va
faire la cote d'ici demain
qu'est-ce que ça va changer le ton à
ottawa est ce que ça va permettre de
tourner la page tour sur toute cette
affaire snc lavalin moi je suis pas
certaine patrice parce que les grandes
lignes de ce budget là on les
connaissait déjà on avait déjà entendu
parler de voiture électrique on avait
déjà entendu parler de l'accès à la
propriété
si c'est dans ce budget là est ce que
quelque chose là-dedans un gros voie où
je ne l'avais pas vue venir non donc si
ce sont des mesures qui sont en ligne
avec ce que le gouvernement libéral fait
jusqu'ici
il ya des nouveautés bien sûr mais il va
falloir probablement plus que ça pour
pour changer le temps à ottawa
mais c'est quand même un élément
important un chapitre important dans le
dans le cycle pré électorale parce que à
partir de maintenant les autres partis
vont pouvoir réagir à ça ils ont les
données financières du gouvernement ils
ont leurs prévisions ils ont leurs
programmes principaux qu'il projette
alors les conservateurs les
néo-démocrates les bloquer son pouvoir
prenne maintenant mieux présenter les
leur répliquer à ce que le gouvernement
présente ses très bien vrai c'est la
madeleine et d'ailleurs est ce que le
ministre a pu commencer à parler ou bien
on est encore dans ce dans ce délai
assez pour ça parce qu'on va vous le
montrez là on a pu parce que les
libéraux étaient presque plus rapide à
la fin dans cette joute parlementaire il
le ministre a déposé le budget de telle
façon qu'on a pu parler de son contenu
même si les conservateurs avait ajouté
des votes et voulait qu'on attend du
nerf de l'audition faire de
l'obstruction ça n'a pas fonctionné
voilà a tout de suite madeleine d'alors
michel c'est au jury
rené vézina tour de table mené visitant
d'abord impression générale de ce budget
morneau ben c'est pas mal ce coma ce
qu'on attendait sauf que c'est bon
permettez patrice il ya quand même
quelques jus de l' esprit là dedans faut
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont et
pts et de permettre à d
qui n'ont pas acheté d'une première
propriété de retirer jusqu'à 35 mille
dollars dans leurs aires pour le régime
d'accès à la propriété
il faut avoir trente cinq mille dollars
dans son arrêt pour commencer il y en
eut des données cette semaine qui disait
que dans l'ensemble de la population
il ya déjà une personne sur vite qu un
reér qui voit puiser dedans simplement
pour payer les fins de mois
alors pour la vie au jour le jour alors
d'imaginer qu'on va pouvoir même galère
mais je trouve que c'est leur en
demander beaucoup l'idée la
participation des ch est une excellente
idée ça c'est intéressant cet innovateur
parce que là on arrive avec une avec une
aide au financement qu'on rembourse rome
et à la vente de la propriété
on demande aux gens pour qu'on comprenne
bien la mesure rené et michel si on
demande aux gens mais désormais on prend
leur demande et pour certains types de
maisons là mais de financer non pas 100
% de la propriété mais 90% prix y était
et est donc c'est des charges moins
lourdes au départ d'entrée de jeu mais
vous savez avec le prix qu'ils doivent
cesser de répéter ou à travers le pays
ça dépend où
mais là on commence à voir un léger
flottement mais je trouve que de dire
parfait aller chercher 35000 dollars
dans votre reér je connais pas beaucoup
de jeunes de 25 ans de 26 ans qui ont
vingt trente mille 5000 $ de l'heure
d'autre part la question du 250 $ pour
la requalification des travailleurs
parfait quand vous êtes jeunes
le problème c'est souvent des justement
les travailleurs âgés d'entre eux sont
dépassés par le bouleversement du marché
du travail
ça leur fera pas beaucoup pour se
requalifier quand vous avez 55 56 ans
puis vous avez 250 dollars par anissa
sera pas suffisant ce soit pas ainsi
tête
quant à moi je pense qu'il aurait fallu
aller ciblé dgo il a alors donné
carrément de quoi s'absenter du milieu
du travail pendant un temps pour aller
chercher la formation supplémentaires
dont ils ont besoin le ratio de la dette
par rapport au produit intérieur brut on
voit qu'elle descend le dessin parfait
savez il ya rien de tel qu'une tendance
continue à mener il ya des bugs
hélas cette année on pense que
l'économie canadienne pourra pas être
aussi vigoureuse
moi je ferai attention avec ces
projections là c'est toujours la même
chose pour un internet dire qu'il va
falloir attendre jusqu'à 2000
prend on soin pts et en europe peut-être
des colonies sur mars à ce moment là ce
qui se passe sur qu'internet va
ressembler et c'est parce que c'est
internet haute vitesse patrice c'est
l'accès internet tout court le problème
et c'est là dessus qu'il faudra agir
alors eh bien ils chérissent et pendant
qu'on voit le vote le fameux vote que
les conservateurs ont forcé mais c'était
là c'est beaucoup moins utile pour eux
deux niveaux ce traité pour le point de
vue stratégique parce qu'on a pu parler
du contenu du budget il on serait aussi
un retard des bons avec ce qu'ils ont
pas vu ce monsieur mono qui est allé
déposer en chambre les documents et à ce
moment là c'est pas un outrage à la
chambre d'en parler s'ils ont été
déposées donc a dit joël ville de le
huis clos est à 4 heures et ceux qui
tablent et voilà et on appuie donc en
parler et c'est très bien parce qu'on
aurait pu veiller tard quand on dit
alors michel ses premières impressions
d'abord c'est un budget politique très
ciblée c'est pas un budget rempli de
bonbons mais les budgets de rapidement
bon ça marchait le chocolat sera
brillant ministre aujourd'hui au québec
je pense que c'est très ciblé et badens
et ciblées dans la queue pour aller
chercher la clientèle du npd et c'est
tout à fait exact
toute la question de l'assurance
médicaments il y en a une au québec mais
la raison province est un vrai problème
pour des gens allons donc de l'aide pour
ceux qui ont des maladies rares et donc
des médicaments qui coûte très cher
d'une part d'une aide directe
d'autre part on va créer une agence
canadienne du médicament pour qu'on peut
s'acheter un gros écouter mais si les
prises pour faire baisser les prix c'est
dingue ça c'est un programme de québec
solidaire ça vous donne une idée assez
peur alors donc il ya vraiment des
choses s'il est là devant vous pour
aller chercher un électorat plus
progressistes plus à gauche
pour le reste je
s'il ya beaucoup de cosmétiques la
relève est bien raison travailleur qui a
cinquante trois enfants qui vont vouloir
se recycler dans quelque chose qui va
avoir quoi trois ans de 250 $ dans son
compte de la formation
ça ne l'aide pas énormément les jeunes
qui veulent des milléniaux ça va être
pour aider les milenio riche repas pour
aînés les mini ordinaire à s'acheter des
maisons mais ça donne l'impression que
le gouvernement ne nous donne pas et en
os le contrôle des finances
il ya peut-être pas le contrôle du
déficit mais là le contrôle des finances
publiques
et ça c'est important des milieux
financiers aujourd'hui lavaur dire bon
sont convenus au déficit zéro mais c'est
pas si important que ça
si on regarde la le ratio de paisibles
et c'est cette sacro-sainte règle du
déficit zéro est remise en question
depuis fort longtemps par beaucoup
d'économies et c'est rude gens
d'affaires qui dit il faut pas devenir
fou 6 à 1 % du pib c'est viable
c'est finalement gars capable de faire
des déficits on devrait être capable ou
aussi rien n'est tout à fait et je
voudrais revenir là dessus c'est
effectivement on peut arriver si on a
une trajectoire à se dire ça ira là ça
pourrait être acceptable mais moi j'ai
bien d'avoir patrice beaumelle à
l'évolution du dollar canadien
parce que ça ça va être un indicateur
est ce que l'on pense que c'est crédible
aujourd'hui ils répètent façon assez
substantielle et ça s'est effritée en
cours de séance
et s'il fallait voir le dollar canadien
a glissé pas parce qu'elle soit une
catastrophe mais c'est un indicateur
sa voix est ce qu'on pense que tout ça
se tient on verse fait dès demain matin
la mégère d'avoir de flottement que ça
peut faire
pour le reste effectivement c'est pas
une parole d'évangile le déficit zéro
c'est tout simplement qu il faut pouvoir
avoir un jour la marge de manoeuvre pour
agir en cas de coup dur
et la belle gouvernement est en train de
faire un petit peu de coin quant à moi
alors michel ces émissions se résume au
il ya des choses qui étaient attendus là
dedans alors des choses attendues sacré
moins de surprises au maine
c'est à dire aide à l'accès à la
propriété les médicaments producteurs de
lait qui seront mes sens à tous les
détails le sens politiquement c'est très
important patrice parce que ça encore
une fois c'est tracy
les politiques mais on a besoin des
régions rurales et semi rural projets au
québec d'ailleurs que les québec c'est à
moitié de l'industrie laitière
canadienne mais alors beaucoup en
ontario de l'industrie laitière et ça
c'est des comptes et qui peuvent
basculer sont actuellement très souvent
libéraux qui pourrait basculer aux
conservateurs alors à l'y aider les
producteurs de lait est ce que ça veut
dire dans une communauté devra elle
quand la femme vont bien mince s c'est
extrêmement important alors on dire deux
mots le chèque ce radar le chèque s'en
viennent il ya des détails à monsieur
monsieur trudeau foire à lait dans les
fermes et bien à quelqu'un de prendre la
campagne électorale ça veut dire alors
mais ce que j'allais dire c'est comme
c'étaient des mesures puis les voitures
électriques et tout ça des mesures qui
peuvent être très intéressant de mai qui
était attendu est ce qu'il ya un facteur
quand même
waouh assez pour sortir justin trudeau
de cette crise qui n'en finit plus avec
un centime à wallemme celle ci à court
terme pas demain matin mais comme toutes
les crises un moment donné il faut
l'alimenter si on veut qu'elle dure
pilote il ya plus beaucoup
d'alimentation possible c'est que crise
là alors c'est quelque chose qui va
s'éteindre tranquillement on le voyait
plus le temps passe plus consommateurs
essaient de coude de crier fort sur
cette crise
ce cadre international car dalle pour
peu que ce truc dont on soit plus habile
que de nomen libéral pour donner même la
mecque la lnah pour s occuper de la
division des pouvoirs entre molière en
général d'une baisse de justice faut
plus qu'il fasse mon erreur comme ça
c'est trop souvent c'est une situation
dalle qui reste de ce qui va stopper
tranquillement 6 ton très bien rené
vézina
donc vous dites vous surveillez le
dollar est notamment parce que la valeur
du dollar canadien par rapport au dollar
américain
c'est vraiment un baromètre c'est un
petit peu le canari dans la mine de s'il
fallait que commence à flétrir ce à dire
qu'on on imaginerait dans l'ensemble des
milieux concernés dont on est peut-être
dans une glace est un peu mince mais
enfin pour l'instant des projections
verra bien ce carnet effectivement
c'était pas mal a tendu il n'y a pas de
facteur est éblouissant la dame n'y a
pas non plus trop de méchante surprise
je rajoute un élément sa maîtresse et
les collègues des médias
il ya quand même 600 millions de dollars
pour l'industrie des médias qui
évidemment traverse une période très
dont un crédit et ça vous savez c'est
vraiment des détails mais on va en
parler
un crédit de 15 % pour un abonnement à
des publications numériques
donc pour inciter les gens à pouvoir
aller peut-être vers ce que l'on offre
ici les dommages majeurs que ça sera pas
sur les grands médias internationaux
facebook et compagnie à leurs ovaires
est ce que ça donne il y aura
probablement les petites mesures comme
sont intéressantes qu'on découvrira au
fur et à mesure mais dans l'ensemble
c'est pas mal ce qu'on nous avait
annoncé intéressant patrice parce que
dorénavant les budgets c'est se poser de
sacro saint secret confidentiel et même
la plupart du temps avant même le dépôt
du budget on a l'essentiel de ce qui
sera annoncé ces particules oui c'est
rare les budgets on a maintenant une
immense sourire
comme il ya fort longtemps il y avait
aussi beaucoup de mesures à l'époque la
qui touchait les les taxes sur le tabac
les cigarettes michel il y avait
plusieurs mesures fiscales c'est
beaucoup plus plus plus calme sur ce
front au là y'a pas pire pas trop de
problèmes de contrebande si vous voulez
parler des détections désirs et de
toutes façons ce qu'on appelait en
anglais les syntaxes les détails sur nos
péchés de l'alcool à l'école de taboye
touchant et sans tellement élevé que
vous allez repartir un problème de
contrôle en dessous si vous dirigez
augmenter un peu plus tel marché et
d'autre part le reste des revenus ce
gouvernement va bien alors on pas besoin
d'aller très bien vous restez là gerald
revoyons les faits saillants avec vous
s'il vous plaît donc tablons général
d'abord oui absolument le déficit
presque 20 milliards de dollars
c'est ce qui est annoncé et dans les
faits saillants donc bonification de
l'aide à l'achat d'une première
propriété c'est un nouveau programme
qu'on met en place pour aider
les nouveaux acheteurs pas
nécessairement riches là parce que c'est
pas des maisons à 1 millions qu'on va
acheter avec ça il faut 7 à peu près
entre 400 et 500 milles maximum les
propriétés donc dans certains marchés
c'est déjà quand même assez élevé donc
bonification de l'aide à l'achat d'une
première propriété avec le régime
d'accès à la propriété qui passe de
25000 à 35000 dollars un crédit à la
formation pour les travailleurs de 25 à
64 ans qui ont besoin de se former tout
au cours de leur carrière compte tenu
que l'économie change des entreprises
changent l'automatisation
alors c'est un crédit à l'information
pour les années on veut on vient
bonifier augmenté l'exemption de revenus
de travail et d'emploi si vous
travaillez si vous êtes sur le marché du
travail ont bonifié l'exemption savoie
jusqu'à 15000 dollars exemption totale
ou partielle et qui font en sorte que
votre supplément de revenu garanti qui
on parle aux aînés à faible revenu qui
ne sont qu il ne sera pas altérée donc
le revenu de suppléments supplément de
revenu garanti demeure essentiellement
le même avec cette bonification là et
pour les producteurs de lait et les
autres producteurs sous gestion de
l'offre
un appui un soutien de 3 milliards 650
millions de dollars pour compenser les
pertes engendrées par les accords
commerciaux
l'ouverture des marchés sur la gestion
de l'offre est également pour garantir
la valeur des quotas de gestion de
l'offre dans le futur très bien vous
avez rencontré le ministre des finances
dans le huis-clos au général on peut
peut-être un peu me présenter le premier
extrait absolument
l'enjeu principal paix vous l'avez on le
mentionne là depuis une demi heure c'est
vraiment ce déficit déficit après
déficit le budget 2019-2020 devait être
le budget de l'équilibré budgétaire
c'est une promesse qui n'est pas tenu
par les libéraux on a parlé de cela avec
les ministres morneau mais en même temps
je sais je sais que d'être responsable
au niveau fiscal est très important et
c'est pour ça que je suis très heureuse
alors que nous pouvons avoir les
investissements comme nous avons
expliqué mais en même temps une
diminuation de notre diminuation de
notre déficit chaque année ça veut dire
que notre bilan et mieux aujourd'hui que
l'année avant et l'année vent ça donc
c'est une approche responsable
mais avec les investissements pour pour
les canadiennes y compris les québécois
mais c'est une promesse brisée vous
aviez promis l'équilibré budgétaire vous
ne l'avez pas respecté
bien sûr il y a toujours les changements
dans l'économie ça c'est très amicaux
nous y voit bien les candidats bien
annonces économiques depuis 83 %
croissance en 2018 c'est très bon c'est
très bon de rentrer d'un site vous
devriez être à l'équilibré budgétaire
revenir à l'équilibré au but et je veux
travailler confessions récession pour
nous je crois que la chose important
d'avoir des investissements parce que de
cette façon on peut continuer avec une
bonne approche pour notre économie
donc on préfère investir c'est ce qu'il
vous à ces jeunes y compris les investir
puis on va mettre au défi les
conservateurs en dix ans ses soeurs
montrez moi ou vous aller couper dans ce
qu'on a annoncé
exactement montrez-nous à quel endroit
il faut faire des compressions net à 20
milliards de déficit
qu'est ce qu'on doit supprimer pour
revenir absolument au déficit zéro
rappelle que le canada une note de
crédit de triple a c'est un des pays
dont les finances publiques sont les
plus solides dans le monde on emprunte
pour presque rien sur les marchés
présentement
donc ils ocde le fmi le rappelle les
grands acteurs internationaux les
économistes le disent il est possible et
c'est sans doute le meilleur moment pour
emprunter pour investir c'est ça le
message du ministre morneau est ce que
face à cela l'équilibré budgétaire le
déficit de 0,7 cette sacro saints 17-0
qu'on s'est donné au fil du temps doit
absolument être atteint sur un budget de
plus de 330 milliards sur une économie
de 2300 milliards de dollars jusqu'à
quel point c'est important d'y arriver
et donc c'est pour ça que le ministre
dit nous on préfère investir on préfère
stimuler l'économie
parce que si on se met à couper ça va
ralentir l'économie mais je
je me demande quand même patrice s'il ya
une récession s conserva 50 milliards de
déficit si les taux d'intérêt se mettent
à monter est ce qu'on s'en va à 50
milliards de dollars de déficit et donc
on a pas profité
la croissance économique est très forte
dans les dernières années qui est le
meilleur moment aussi pour revenir à une
forme d'équilibré budgétaire et on
laisse donc à plus tard ce ce résultat
ce trajet ce travail pour revenir à
l'équilibré très bien madeleine je veux
que vous me reparler de l'assurance
médicaments parce que ce sera une partie
importante de la plateforme libérale on
le présume lors de la prochaine campagne
électorale
là les gens qui nous écoutent là parce
qu'on a donnée will création d'une
agence canadienne etc
qu'est ce que ça change pour les gens
qui achètent des médicaments
demain matin rien non ça peut
éventuellement changer mes potes demain
matin parce que ce programme là il n'est
pas encore en place mais éventuellement
les médicaments vont coûter moins cher
on y au canada un des pays au monde où
on paie des médicaments les plus chers
et ce qui est compliqué en ce moment
c'est que le gouvernement a très très
peu de d'informations sur ce que
d'autres pays ps que des agences privées
paient pour leurs médicaments
donc on veut essayer de changer le
rapport de force face aux producteurs de
médicaments et l'eau ce qui arrive c'est
cette agence de médicaments là va
pouvoir à la fois accepté de d'accepter
des médicaments qui y entrent au pays à
la condition qu'on s'entend sur un prix
parce qu'en ce moment ce sont deux
organismes différents qui font le
travail
un qui accepte les médicaments au canada
et l'autre qui s'entend sur un prix donc
finalement pour avoir un meilleur de
rapport de force on veut faire
chapeauter ces deux aspects la de la
dynamique des médicaments sous une seule
même agence et on croit qu'on va réussir
à faire des économies on parlait tout à
l'heure de 3 milliards de dollars pour
les médicaments
ça c'est pour les pays qui sont le plus
touchés c'est pas nécessairement les
québécois qui vont à davantage en
bénéficier parce que l'assurance
médicaments elle n'est pas égale partout
on a véritablement une courte pointe au
pays et les québécois sont généralement
bien assurée mais si les prix des
médicaments baisse
au québec éventuellement des québécois
pourraient avoir plus d'argent dans
leurs poches si par exemple ils se font
rembourser à 80% leur médicament bien le
petit 20% qui reste s'il est moins cher
évidemment ça va être plus d'argent dans
les poches des québécois mais la marge
elle est peut être moins importante au
québec qu'ailleurs d'accord mais ceux
qui imaginaient un programme canadien
d'assurance médicaments pour remplacer
entend plus patrice ça sera pas long oui
comme un autre alors mais bon pendant
qu'elle qu'elle se rebranche 1 voilà ben
voilà des noms gérald alors ceux qui
croyaient qu'on a on était de 20 le
début d'un processus qui allait nous
mener à une assurance médicaments public
pour tous partout au canada
est ce que c'est ça ou c'est pas ça
c'est en jette les bases de cette idée
là mais on n'y est pas encore faut
savoir que l'année dernière dans le
gouvernement
dans le dernier budget le gouvernement
avait annoncé la création d'un groupe de
travail pour étudier cette question là
il ya un rapport préliminaire qui a été
rendue publique il ya environ un mois et
la première recommandation c'était
justement pour s'attaquer aux prix des
médicaments parce qu'on disait avant
même d'avoir une assurance médicaments
on peut s'attaquer aux prix pour ce qui
est de l'assurance médicaments
ça va venir peut-être le rapport
subséquents d'ici là elle était va nous
mener à peut-être une option parce qu'en
ce moment il ya on parlait d'une
courtepointe tout à l'heure le système
privé et public des médicaments qui sont
couverts dans certaines provinces et
qu'ils ne le sont pas dans d'autres
alors comment essayer de faire un tout
cohérent
est-ce qu'on essaie tout simplement de
combler les écarts de ceux qui ne sont
pas assurés du tout où on essaie
d'europe repartir à zéro et essayer
d'avoir un système compréhensif avec
avec tout un système public
c'est ce sont des décisions qui devront
être prises mais on n'est pas encore en
s'envolant nécessairement vers
l'universel mais davantage le
remplacement en fait l'accompagnement
des personnes qui n'ont pas de
deux couvertures de médicaments pour
couvrir leurs médicaments
il ya plein d'entreprises qui ont des
régimes privés mais le régime public
n'est pas là pour beaucoup de gens mais
un système universel viendrait remplir
en place et lancent l'ensemble des
régimes d'assurance médicaments
ça vient ça vient de couper l'herbe sous
le pied du parti néo-démocrate qui en
faisait deux mesures phares mais en même
temps les néo m démocrates pourront dire
nous on a un système on a déjà une idée
en place alors que les libéraux arrivent
avec une idée de système et où un plan
de peut-être avoir quelque chose donc on
pourra sentir que probablement que ce
sera la défense des néo-démocrates de
dire que on peut être une idée plus plus
évolué et plus complète de ce qu'ils
veulent faire
où les libéraux arriveront en fin de
l'été avec une première sursaut de
l'enveloppé pour la campagne électorale
puis voudront faire campagne là dessus
pour aller raflé entre autres le vote je
ne paie des lacs est resté fort possible
et sa frappe passer bon j'explique aux
gens ce qui se passe en chambre
madeleine a les mains des secteurs on
est encore dans en attente du dépôt a
fait le minet s'occupe déposer le
document c'est pour ça qu'on l'a pu en
parler mais ils n'ont pas pu parler
encore et là les conservateurs sont en
train on va l'écouter quelques secondes
ils font de l'obstruction du coup il
allait mettre fin aux audiences du
comité
bref le personnel libéral n'aurait pas
dû faire circuler cette motion
alors que nous étions en train d'en
prendre connaissance dans la salle de
comité parfois on se plaint sur la fuite
de rapports toutefois le secret des
séances à huis clos ne s'applique pas
aux motions réclamant nous dit ce qui
suit je cite la chambre par le passé
concernant la publication de rapports
des comités à huis clos
il s'agit d'un atteinte aux privilèges
alors voilà atteinte aux privilèges je
pense qu'on est furieux du côté
conservateur parce que le ministe
morneau a pu malgré tout déposer son
budget même s'ils n'ont pas faire encore
la lecture
avec moi serge coulombe économiste
professeur titulaire au département de
sciences économiques université d'ottawa
monsieur coulon vous m'entendez il ya
très bien quand vous allez bien alors
vous en avez vu des budgets je vous le
rende d'abord une un titre une
impression générale comment vous avez
reçu quatrième budget morneau et bien du
point de vue du point de vue de la
question de de l'équilibré budgétaire
qui fait la manche est présentement ils
ont ils perçu ces saignements ils ont
laissé tomber la recherche de
l'équilibré budgétaire
durant le premier mandat rapidement ils
se sont rendus compte que c'était une
bonne chose de le laisser tomber c'est
un choix politique
monsieur roy noter que du point de vue
économique ça se défend très bien étant
donné la marge de manoeuvre que le
gouvernement canadien a présentement
pour par son déficit et par son faible
niveau d'endettement également justement
ouvrons une parenthèse la tum succulent
il ya des chapelles en économie ne pense
pas cependant science exacte il ya des
points de vue à des opinions à l'heure
actuelle si vous regardez l'ensemble des
économistes qui qui qui qui sont
importants au pays
est ce qu'une majorité ou pas une
majorité est plutôt d'accord avec le
fait que faut pas en faire une obsession
du déficit zéro où on en est dans les
points le point de vue là dessus oui
juste mes yeux un changement au cours
des trois quatre dernières années et
maintenant on peut dire qu'il ya presque
un consensus de la part des principaux
économistes mondiaux autant américains
et européens que canadiens que liquider
budgétaire n'est pas nécessairement je
dis bien nécessaire mais ça ça peut être
un bon objectif mais c'est pas le seul
objectif possible actuellement surtout
pour un pays comme le canada qui est peu
endettée bon et noter que ceci découle
de l'attrait de la faiblesse des taux
d'intérêt le gouvernant canadien peut
emprunter à des coûts très très faible
et s'il peut investir dans des mesures
structurantes de l'économie
c'est une autre solution qui se défend
également
ça ne veut pas dire que c'est meilleur
que date indiquée des budgets
mais du point de vue de la science
économique il n'y a rien qui contredit
le fait d'avoir un déficit qui sommes
tous ont été très fermes environ 0
points 7 % du pib pour l'année courante
c'est très loin du seuil de dangerosité
qu'on a au niveau international qui est
à 3 pour 5 c 4 à 5 fois plus élevés là
là j'entends les gens réagissent pas ce
que ça veut dire on est très peu endetté
au canada 705 milliards le dernier
chiffre je crois c'est la dette et bien
sûr enfin difficile donc de 9 milliards
cette année ça va s'ajouter à la dette
etc
si peu endettées sa 700 milliards oui
c'est fait 30% du pib
et c'est le ratio dette au pib et noter
qu'encore une fois un critère de succès
quand c'est dangereux ici environ 70% du
pib
c'est ce qu'on atteignait en 1993 donc
maintenant on est très très loin d'un
seuil de danger et son ratio dette au
pib
il continue à descendre tranquillement
certes mais il est tellement faible
il continue à diminuer donc d'adopter
plutôt une cible de faire descendre le
ratio dette au pib plutôt que
d'atteindre l'équilibré budgétaire
c'est un objectif qui se défend d'accord
d'accord oui oui oui mais l'os est très
claire par ailleurs dans les mesures
qu'est ce qui vous a frappé qu'est ce
que vous retenez comme importants et
bien c'est des mesures qui frappent
beaucoup certaines personnes qui sont de
nature à voter pour le npd ou pour les
libéraux voyez vous c'est donc ils
vivent
c'est vraiment un budget qui de type néo
démocrates par là je m'explique
voyez-vous la bonification du de
l'exemption du supplément du revenu
garanti face et ça va pour les gens qui
gagnent entre 10000 et 20000 dollars par
année et qui sont pauvres parce qu'ils
reçoivent le supplément de revenu
garanti
c'est plus traduit par 4000 $ de plus
par année dans leur poche
voyez vous ce serait intéressant même
que le goal en du québec taille
également dans cette voie de façon à
encourager les gens qui sont retraités
qui n'ont que le faible somme de revenus
par année de ne pas perdre 7
some lorsqu'ils décident de travailler
les entreprises devraient accueillir
chaleureusement cette mesure puisqu'ils
sont très intéressés à embaucher dans
cette période de pénurie de
main-d'oeuvre des gens qui ont autant
d'expérience ça c'est une des mesures
ça c'est important vous dites ça fait
une vraie effectivement avec le montant
d'une aide mentionné ça fait une vraie
différence là oui ça fait une différence
dans le bien-être d'un sous-groupe de la
population qui avouons le avait été un
peu oubliée puisque le montant
d'admissibilité de déductions n'avait
pas été renouvelé depuis 2008
donc à chaque année ceux qui voulaient
travailler équité sur le supplément de
revenu garanti paient de plus en plus
d'impôts donc très bien autre mesure oui
une autre mesure qui qui est extrêmement
intéressante concerne la location
canadienne pour la formation
encore une fois ça vise l'offre de
main-d'oeuvre c'est un nouveau programme
complètement décidé un peu à partir de
rien qui va donner 250 $ par année dans
un fond quand on travaille à temps plein
et on fait à les accumuler jusqu'à 5000
$ maximum qu'est ce qu'on fait avec cet
argent là c'est qu'on peut l'utiliser
pour la formation professionnelle
donc si on y en a qui recevra 250
dollars c'est les personnes qui vont
faire de la formation professionnelle
c'est eux qui vont faire cesser aussi
c'est intéressant c'est pas donner aux
universités aux écoles c'est donner aux
gens plusieurs personnes aujourd'hui à
en milieu de carrière ont parfois l'idée
d'aller suivre un cours d'un mois ou
deux mois pour changer un peu de
vocations et avec ce programme on
facilite de ce changement donc on
facilite l'ajustement à l'offre de
main-d'oeuvre et en même temps aussi on
veut faciliter le lien avec le régime
d'assurance-emploi donc finalement c'est
un programme qui risque d'avoir beaucoup
de succès du point de vue de la
formation de la main-d'oeuvre et il faut
le faut pas oublier aussi monsieur roy
l'accès à la propriété ou est-ce qu'on a
un petit peu copié ce qui était fait à
la ville de montréal mais c'est un
programme de partage de risque
finalement pour les premiers acheteurs
de propriétés maintenant ils vont
pouvoir payer 10 % - 2
de paiements hypothécaires par mois si
c'est une maison neuve et 5% - et par
quel miracle et bien c'est tout
simplement la schl qui va devenir co
partenaire dans la chaude à la propriété
elle va participer à l'éventuel gain ou
de perte de capital donc c'est un autre
régime tout à fait intéressant couplée à
l'augmentation de la limite du rap qui
risque d'avoir une incidence importante
sur les personnes on le sentait
aujourd'hui dans le budget dans la dans
le huis clos qu'il y avait des mesures
qui touchait beaucoup les gens et on
sait très exactement les sauces y
voyez-vous parce que un peu ça veut dire
si vous voulez vraiment profiter de ces
mesures-là remettez-nous pouvoir parce
que peut-être mais c'est pas c'est pas
du saupoudrage comme on l'a vu dans le
passé
c'est vraiment des mesures qui touchent
ces délices fait du clientélisme
les premiers acheteurs d'un côté ceux
qui veulent aller faire de la formation
de londres les personnes âgées de
l'autre on nous avait dit très bien
serge couleurs
en conclusion est ce que vous vous
attendiez par ailleurs à plus à moins
j'ai été surpris surpris par l'ampleur
des mesures et un peu déçu que certaines
soient mises en oeuvre uniquement après
la prochaine élection ça c'est que
voulez vous aussi la politique mais
c'est du point de vue économique je
pense que c'est un budget qui est
satisfaisant mais qui qui également sur
le plan politique est très intéressant
serge coulombe économiste à l'université
des personnes en sciences économiques à
l'inversé d'un terroir merci c'est
toujours un plaisir à la prochaine voire
au revoir alors il ya des réactions bien
sûr à ce budget c'est le côté scrocca
bon soit vous êtes accompagné de monique
moreau de la fédération canadienne de
l'entreprise indépendante
voilà avec ce budget qui comprend
quelques mesures entre autres pour
faciliter la formation des travailleurs
mais madame moreau ça ne vous satisfait
pas totalement mais on aurait aimé voir
plus de mesures structurelles pour
améliorer le rôle de l'entrepreneur dans
la formation est ce qu'on aura des
situations où un employé de construction
mettons pour
parti pour un cours culinaires pendant
quatre semaines est ce que l'employeur
le choix de lui aider dans leur la
formation et aussi quand est-ce qu'ils
vont prendre cette formation donc manque
de détails en ce moment justement c'est
ça et sûrement on va les voir dans les
prochaines semaines
évidemment avec les élections très
proches mais pour nous ce qui va nous
aider à mousser cette programme si vous
voulez cible plus de détails est aussi
fixé le rôle de l'entrepreneur dont ceux
ci et le gouvernement annonce un déficit
ont un peu en dessous de la barre des 20
milliards de dollars
de quelle manière ça ça va toucher les
petites entreprises au canada la plupart
des petites entreprises au canada les
entrepreneurs peuvent pas se permettre
des groupes difficiles de même ton pour
eux il regarde ça avec une inquiétude il
voit des impôts peut-être de demain qui
va augmenter pour payer pour cette
grande dépense donc on regarde ça avec
beaucoup d'attention et un peu
d'inquiétude
madame moreau je vous remercie beaucoup
alors madame moraux de la fédération
canadienne des entreprises indépendantes
donc un vent d'inquiétude avec le dépôt
de ce budget 4e budget du gouvernement
libéral
merci merci est un côté trop cas merci
on se retrouve avec d'autres réactions
je vous rappelle mesdames et messieurs
que si on n'a pas gerald sur l'app
entendu le chef de pollution et à les
autres politiciens qui viennent
habituellement devant les micros
commenter le budget c'est que le
ministre n'a pas commencé à livrer son
discours du budget parce que les
conservateurs font de l'obstruction
on a pu nous en parler dès 16h avec vous
et tous les tells tous les détails parce
que le minet soit plus quand même
rapidement mettre déposer le discours du
budget en chambre alors il s'est
tellement je vois sa patrie
aussi j'en ai quand même pas mal et donc
quand on est arrivé ici
le ministre était déjà là il nous
attendait parce qu'il avait déjà déposé
le budget alors il a voulu court
circuiter la manoeuvre de l'opposition
officielle en déposant le budget tout de
suite et en faisant qu'on en parle
depuis 1h finalement à l'antenne a
expliqué les mesures en long et en large
on va si vous le voulez bien gérant je
vous demande et parce qu'il ya des gens
qui se joignent à nous je dis aux gens
de la première chaîne qu'il y aura vos
émissions régulières dans une 25 minutes
17h30 aura le jeu avec patrice etc et on
vous allez retrouver vos télés journaux
régionaux partout au pays à 18h bien
entendu nous on va continuer la la cette
émission spéciale parce que le ministre
n'a pas encore parlé on va écouter les
premières minutes de son discours il y
aura des réactions mais ce chiffre de
l'opposition et cetera mais revenons au
tableau à généraux faits saillants si
vous le voulez bien pour les gens qui se
joignent à nous d'abord revenus dépenses
qui nous frappe gerald c'est qu'il ya un
déficit on l'a presque pas vu peut-être
le tableau avant messieurs dames oui
difficile et qui fait jaser ce difficile
oui bien sûr parce que du côté des
libéraux on maintient que ce n'est pas
important de revenir à l'équilibré
budgétaire
monsieur harper avant de partir avant de
quitter pouvoir en 2015 à son dernier
budget flaherty monsieur oliver tovey
extrêmement important d'être l'
équilibre budgétaire vise l équilibre
budgétaire
ici même si on a promis en 2015 d'être à
l'équilibré budgétaire dans le budget
d'aujourd'hui on est en déficit 19
milliards 800 millions et il n'y a pas
de cible de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire
on le fait ce déficit parce qu'on dit
qu'on investit dans l'économie
canadienne et dans les canadiens dans
les faits saillants les quatre faits
saillants je vous dirais de ce budget
bonification de l'aide à l'achat d'une
première propriété
on veut aider les jeunes ménages à avoir
accès à la propriété dans un pays où les
prix ont beaucoup augmenté dans les
dernières années
toronto vancouver mais montréal aussi
présentement c'est en train d'augmenter
donc on bonifie par exemple le régime
d'accès à la propriété
on va permettre aux gens d'avoir des
participations un prêt sans intérêt en
quelque sorte de la société canadienne
d'hypothèques et de logement
parce que l'économie change et parce
qu'il y a de l'automatisation et parce
qu'il faut améliorer la productivité et
parce qu'il faut changer d'emploi ou de
type d'emploi à l'intérieur de son
entreprise
on crée un crédit à la formation un peu
comme on a vu à singapour dans les
dernières années pour les travailleurs
de 25 à 64 ans d'un crédit de 250 $ par
année jusqu'à 5000 cumulé que vous
pouvez utiliser pour aller au collège au
cégep à l'université pour suivre une
formation
les aînés ont bonifié l'exemption du
revenu de travail donc à 100% pour les
premiers 5000 $ de travail et 10000
dollars ensuite à 50% pour faire en
sorte que votre supplément de revenu
garanti ne soit pas à baisser parce que
vous travaillez parce que vous allez
travailler davantage donc ça c'est pour
les indices une mesure quand même
importante qui va toucher beaucoup de
canadiens de 65 70 75 ans même qui
veulent travailler qui travaille encore
et pour les producteurs qui sont sous
gestion de l'offre compte tenu des
accords commerciaux
on a un soutien de 3 milliards 650
millions qui prévoit une compensation
pour les pertes de marché avec
l'ouverture du marché canadien notamment
dans le lait mais qui prévoit également
un milliard et demi pour s'assurer de la
valeur des quotas de production qui sont
sous gestion de l'offre
on a beaucoup parlé gerald 2 à 20,1 en
attendu ce budget est ce qu'il y aurait
de l'argent supplémentaire pour le
transport en commun la ville de québec a
levé la main bon montréal vancouver en
fait toutes les grandes villes
canadiennes ont des besoins énormes en
transport en commun
y at il quelque chose y a rien de
nouveau dans ce budget sur le plan des
infrastructures et du développement
le tramway à québec par exemple le rsa
déjà été annoncé mais le tramway de
québec où la ligne bleue ce sont des
travaux et des projets qui sont en
négociation nous a dit le ministre
morneau il s'est même un peu d engager
en disant ça dépend des municipalités ça
dépend également des des provinces ces
projets donc on peut pas voulu
l'annoncer là ce que le gouvernement
annonce aujourd'hui c'est tout nous
sommes dans les infrastructures de 2
milliards 200 millions qui est
ponctuelle qui est envoyé aux
municipalités pour les infrastructures
certains trouvent que ça ressemble à un
cadeau électoral parce que ça vient d'un
coup mais on nous dit que c'est tout à
fait normal pour le gouvernement fédéral
compte tenu de ces engagements d'arriver
avec une somme supplémentaire pour
soutenir les les municipalités rester là
je vais aller entendre comme vous la
réaction de la fédération des
municipalités du pays donc estelle côté
vous êtes accompagné de vicki may hamm
voilà la présidente de la fédération
canadienne des municipalités qui est
très contente du dépôt de ce budget en
raison de plusieurs mesures d'abord à
l'injection de 2,2 milliards de dollars
spécifiquement destiné aux municipalités
de quelle manière ça c'est ça vous sera
utile
en fait ce qui est intéressant c'est que
ça va passer par le fonds qui
proviennent de la taxe sur l'essence
donc cet affront qu'on utilise déjà
depuis plusieurs années qui est facile
qui est pris qui est prévisible et puis
qui sert pour les infrastructures que
tous les citoyens peuvent en bénéficier
il qu'on parle des routes dès cette
année on va parler beaucoup des routes
les routes l'eau potable chez terrain
donc et c'est efficace donc on va
pouvoir rapidement pouvoir faire des
projets
de quelle manière allez-vous distribuer
cet argent là mais moi je connais pas le
niveau le détail mais ce que je
comprends c'est que ça va passer tout
comme actuellement au niveau de la taxe
sur l'essence arrive directement dans
les municipalités un calcul qui est fait
et puis municipalité des gens savent
qu'on me guillaume donc injuste
d'oublier m'enfin ça devrait être plutôt
facile mais l'on attend des détails le
rouge et que j'ai pas un grand
effectivement on parle également d'une
somme d'un milliard de dollars destiné à
un fonds vert donc une autre bonne
nouvelle pour les municipalités en
matière d'infrastructures entre autres
oui puis c'est une belle marque de
confiance parce que le fonds municipal
vert est géré par la fédération
canadienne des municipalités depuis
presque vingt ans déjà
et là on vient bonifier en ajoutant des
volets que ce soit pour le logement
social
et pour la résilience par rapport aux
changements climatiques et pour la
gestion aussi des infrastructures donc
c'est vraiment ça répond directement aux
demandes de la fédération canadienne des
municipalités
une autre de vos demandes pour ce budget
là c'était de connecter l'ensemble des
canadiens à internet haute vitesse
le gouvernement s'engage à le faire
d'ici 2030
est-ce que c'est assez évident selon
vous mais c'est ce qu'on estimait déjà
nous que ça prendrait un peu désolé
voici les bêlements le cleaner plus tard
peut enfin donner les premiers mots de
son discours sur le budget si vous le
voulez bien même de monsieur on va
l'écouter
[Applaudissements]
sa résidence la dernière loge et à
toronto j'ai rencontré des jeunes au
boxing club la semaine les jeunes
voulaient s'amuser mais il avait des
questions et il n'est pas évident qu'il
se soucie beaucoup de leurs compagnons
de leurs communautés du monde qui les
entoure il s'agissait d'un beau rappel
de ce qui est en jeu et des personnes
qui comptent sur nous pour bien faire
des choses qui commente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'aurais compris mesdames et messieurs
que c'est pas votre télé qui fait défaut
c'est les conservateurs en chambre qui
font du brouhaha pour éviter que le
minet soit audible que sa voix vous
atteindre donc voilà ça c'est réussi sur
ce plan là en tout cas les mesures d'
obstruction gérald madeleine michel c et
rené avait pas fonctionné mais ça
manifestement ça vient de fonctionner je
le sais ça vous rappelle des sommes
qu'on voyait ça davantage à l'époque
mais qu'on était passé à autre chose
on entend des points noirs points de
bordeaux qui essaient de faire des
rappels au règlement pour des broutilles
sans doute mais ça empêche entre deux
d'entendre le
le discours du ministre oui on était
sans qu'on n'était pas assez en autre
chose mais au moins on a pu avoir le
budget ça c'est les changements aux
règlements d'antan souvenez-vous la
l'histoire d'affaires des cloches ou
leurs chances de rester mais on avait un
jour des choses comme ça ça pourrait lui
arriver mais je pense que les
consommateurs c'est en faisant c'est ce
que j'aimerais vous demander à vous et à
madeleine est ce que magna est trop
c'est comme pas assez non oui il ya un
risque politique évidemment complètement
empêcher un couvert de vente fonctionne
et c'est un voeu c'est un dépôt de
budget c'est important pour les
canadiens les canadiens vont vouloir
savoir est-ce qu'ils vont avoir plus
d'argent dans leurs poches de mai matin
oui ou non
donc il ya un risque mais visiblement
les conservateurs pensent qu'il ya
encore du kilométrage à faire avec toute
la sphère snc-lavalin on ne veut surtout
pas la laisser mourir cette histoire là
et c'est en partie pour ça qu'on essaie
de faire de l'obstruction pour permettre
éventuellement à john woo un très bon de
parler davantage alors on est dans cette
dynamique là on veut à tout prix donner
de l'oxygène à cette histoire là pour
qu'elle dure le plus longtemps possible
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'elle sert
en ce moment aux partis d'opposition qui
est également couverte parce que si nous
sommes diffusés actuellement sur la
première chaîne et je re chalut les gens
nous téléspectateurs de la première
chaîne de radio canada c'est que y'a un
dépôt d'un budget c'est le moment
important démocratie à des changements
qui touchent à peu près tous les
citoyens dans ce but de chelsea
gérald vous nous en avait parlé depuis
plus d'une heure les personnes âgées les
gens qui veulent la formation les gens
qui veulent acheter une première
propriété
il y a des il ya des choses qu'il faut
expliquer puis c'est normal de le faire
alors là il ya une limite à bloquer le
chemin ou liberal il ya des éléments
fondamentaux donc dans un budget vous
avez la feuille de route que ce soit le
premier budget qu'on va présenter à
québec jeudi
patrice où il ya des éléments
fondamentaux pour les quatre prochaines
années
là il ya des éléments fondamentaux pour
faire le bilan des quatre dernières
années ce qui s'en vient
en même temps c'est aussi et on l'a fait
remarquer au ministre aujourd'hui une
base une plateforme pour les élections
donc oui les conservateurs aujourd'hui
l'opposition officielle font de
l'obstruction
mais en même temps le jeu politique veut
également que le parti au pouvoir prenne
la place fassent des annonces qui ne
sont pas encore chiffrés qui demeure a
détaillé puis d'ailleurs il y en a
plusieurs de ces mesures aujourd'hui qui
ont été annoncées sont assez
fondamentale qui sont assez
intéressantes qu'on pense à l'assurance
médicaments qu'on pense à l'achat d'une
première propriété le soutien pour les
aînés également les véhicules
électriques etc
il ya beaucoup de mesures qui sont
intéressantes et bonne pour l'économie
et constructive pour l'économie mais
dont les mesures restent à être déployée
détail et puis on se garde soit pour des
annonces d'ici les élections puis durant
la campagne électorale notamment que je
viens raison le sous-texte de dierrey
jeu coulombe l'économiste où le souvenir
tout à l'heure votez pour nous parce
qu'on va pouvoir mettre en place ce
résulat sinon si mesures là vont tomber
dans un puits sans fond rené vézina
quand même il ya des mesures qui vont
changer la dynamique personnes âgées
monsieur que l'on nous disait ça peut
être qu'à 4000 $ de plus pour des
personnes âgées qui reviennent sur le
marché du travail c'est important quand
même oui parce que il faut comprendre
que il ya un phénomène qui pancanadien
c'est qu'on commence à gratter les fonds
de tiroir pour trouver l'effectif
nécessaire pour faire rouler l'économie
il ya problème particulier au québec
avec le vieillissement de la population
mais dans les faits c'est un peu partout
au canada donc tous assurés d'avoir un
maximum utilisaient leur plein potentiel
les gens qui pourraient vouloir
travailler par moments ou bien il boit
pas un avantage parce qu'ils pourraient
perdre des 10
les revenus bien qu'on parlait pas les
qualifications qui n'ont pas les
compétences
alors là il ya quand même un début de
plaindre mais je dirais que par rapport
au fait qu'il faut voter pour avoir
droit à ses promesses
y en a pas beaucoup de promesses de
shanghai elles sont minimes par rapport
à ce qu'on a déjà vu par le passé le
jeudi est un élément intéressant
patrice je vois des commentaires
d'économistes notamment monsieur d'un
bus porter de la bmo qu'ils écoutaient
il faut comprendre peut-être que le pari
du gouvernement
enfin les extras pas mais pour tenir
parce que des revenus fiscaux du dernier
mois le tout dernier mois de l'année en
cours sont supérieurs aux prévisions
on va chercher plus d'argent dans ce qui
a peut-être là d'un facteur de
mitigation par rapport à cette dette
qu'on voit en fait évidemment on peut
pas présumer de ce qui s'en vient mais
on est sur une belle tendance et ça ça
pourrait être intéressant
oui c'est cet argent supplémentaire donc
ces revenus supplémentaires dont
bénéficie le gouvernement le
gouvernement a décidé de les dépenser en
fait ils leur le gouvernement aurait pu
réduire la taille du déficit par rapport
à la dernière mise à jour de l'automne
où on prévoyait justement un déficit
frôlant les 20 milliards de dollars
on a eu environ 5 milliards de dollars
de revenus supplémentaires ou en fait on
a permis d'avoir 5 milliards de mesures
supplémentaires sans toucher finalement
la taille du déficit donc les revenus
ont décidé de les injecter dans
l'économie c'est la stratégie libérale
on pense qu'il vaut mieux donner de
l'oxygène aux gens plutôt que
d'équilibrer budget on pense que c'est
plus payant politiquement ou plus
efficaces aussi pour stimuler la
croissance économique à moyen terme
entre autres avec cette question de la
formation de la main d'oeuvre pour
permettre aux travailleurs de s'adapter
à l'économie de domagné beaucoup de
questions d'anti siete vous êtes vous
allez entendre le ministre parle et
d'anxiété l'économie sport bien un taux
d'emploi qui est qui qui est
impressionnant pas de chômage le plus
bas niveau en 40 ans par contre il ya
des canadiens qui s'inquiètent encore
pour payer leurs factures pour acheter
une première maison pourquoi pour
justement être partie intégrante de
cette économie de demain est là et c'est
ce que le gouvernement veut faire
essayer de toucher à ces points
anxiété en annonçant certains progrès
programmes qui sont quand même assez
large mais qui touchent directement
certaines personnes j'ai été frappé de
voir que l'association des municipalités
du canada mais celle ci un gerald était
assez satisfaite en deuil a quand même
une une injonction d'argent de plus pour
les infrastructures
donc on se sent que ça calme un pull
parce que les attentes étaient énormes
là-dessus michel c n'oublions pas une
chose il ya une élection qui s'en vient
alors la ligne bleue du métro à montréal
d'un tramway à québec des choses comme
ça c'est des belles annonces d'élections
ça aussi faut pas l'oublier
il m'avait disait le gouvernement a
décidé de dépenser l'argent qui entre en
surplus parce que c'est les revenus sont
au delà des prévisions
mais ça aussi c'est c'est de la dépense
plus directement électorale il faut pas
s'attendre à ce que le gouvernement se
prive de le faire pendant une campagne
électorale serait bien dans la foi mais
gouvernement s'est donné un nouvel outil
un d'investissement avec la banque des
infrastructures un immense programme 287
milliards de dollars diab du retard dans
le déploiement de cela rappelez-vous
l'élection de 2015 ont des fonds à
investir dans les infrastructures pour
stimuler l'économie
or depuis quatre ans oui a eu des
annonces qui ont été faits mais beaucoup
plus lentement que prévu parce que ça
prend beaucoup plus de temps que prévu
développer des projets d'infrastructures
on sait qu'il ya certaines la ligne
bleue là on en parle depuis 30 ans 30
donc de dire d'un coup sec qu'on va
régler la ligne bleue qu'on va stimuler
l'économie avec ça ça prend du temps et
donc on va probablement rien on sait
quelque chose là d'ici les élections là
dessus gérald monsieur moore nous vous
en donner d'autres vues et et vous lui
avez posées notamment la question parce
que les producteurs laitiers au pays
attendent ils ont eu un certain nombre
de réponses aujourd'hui on écoute
l'extrait plomb revient on va on va
garder le projeter des gouvernements
précédents devaient 4 milliards de
dollars pour le secteur mais nous savons
que nous devons avoir une station où
exactement comment on pourrait le faire
c'est pour ça que nous avons expliqué
que l'argent est là on va avoir un corps
des discussions pour assurer qu'on a nos
proches qui va être bon pour les y est
donc à quinze acteurs à quand la
précision des annonces des soutiens et
descriptions sont en train d'être fait
en ce moment je suis pas dans la
discrétion mais je suis certain qu'on va
continuer avec notre projet nous voulons
le faire aussi tôt que possible en tout
cas gérard ce serait à vendre
c'est pas garanti j'ai essayé de savoir
ce secteur parce que les producteurs
laitiers les producteurs sous gestion de
l'offre ont besoin de cet argent là mais
au moins il ya des sommes il ya des six
nations
il ya des sommes deux milliards cent
cinquante millions disponibles pour
compenser les accords commerciaux il ya
1 milliard 500 millions c'est un
programme de garantie la valeur des
quotas
maintenant distribuer comme un bon mais
on va aller moi on va aller voir la
réaction tout de suite la fédération des
producteurs de lait en compagnie de la
stèle oui voilà avec monsieur lampron de
la fédération canadienne représentants
des producteurs de lait canada qui
accueille plutôt favorablement ces
investissements du gouvernement plus de
trois milliards
donc c'est une bonne nouvelle on
accueille favorablement cette annonce
claude dans le budget fédéral est
aujourd'hui je pense que le gouvernement
reconnaît les concessions que les
poteaux laitiers au fait des derniers
accords et de quelle manière allez-vous
dépenser ou 10 - espérez vous que cet
argent la soirée partie mais c'est ce
dont on demande se sont répartis par
tout les producteurs et qui est qui qui
table mais à travers le canada selon le
part de marché on veut que ce soit ou
non des le même pas des pertes compte
qu'ils ont subie à travers le canada
et là on n'a pas encore le détail
justement de la façon dont cet argent le
sera répartie à l'échelle du pays est ce
que ça c'est une source d'inquiétude
non
parce qu on a fondé les groupes de
travail qui ont travaillé la menace
bibeau était nommé dernièrement on va le
rencontrer la semaine prochaine puis on
va je pense que l'important stocker des
annonces dans le budget aujourd'hui ça a
été fait on des contrats et donc il ya
pas encore d'argent pour le nouvel alena
qui a été négocié avec les etats-unis le
mexique
à ce compte là est-ce que vous avez vous
gardez vos attentes assez élevé comme
pour la renégociation des autres accords
avec l'europe et le partenariat
transpacifique non mais ce que je
comprend ainsi qu'alex éclatante mai
pour ratifier un car on se pose
qu'est-ce qui va arriver avec toutes
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent de
l'international puis mec mais je pense
la porte est ouverte aussi à reconnaître
les dommages préfet d'istres des tiers
alors un soupir de soulagement pour les
producteurs laitiers du canada voilà
patrice un son un autre son de cloche
relativement positif après le dépôt de
ces budgets on n'est pas ce qu'il
imaginait une campagne merci est elle
est imaginée messieurs dames une
campagne électorale si on n'avait pas
fait la paix avec les producteurs
laitiers s'arrêter l'ont longtemps
michel cct longtin d'autre part en
s'assurant que peut-être pas le check
complet mais un peu d'argent soit entrée
dans l'achat qu'une des fermes détient
au canada et en ontario dans des régions
rurales da des régions qui sont
importants pour la réélection du parti
libéral on s'assure que je trie
deauville et menez ou un des reçus quand
simon penser là et ça aussi c'est
important dans une dans une élection
d'autre part
c'étaient les producteurs laitiers
effectivement on bu la tasse laquelle
les accords de m.le change ont été ont
été signés et voulait peut-être pas
c'était l'une des domaines avait promis
à la police tenait des demandes de
monsieur legault an mettant cet argent
là sur la table ça empêche un certain
nombre de choses qui qui aurait pu être
très désagréable vous la voyez vous
marie claude ribaux a été nommé à
l'agriculture aussi la première femme à
accéder à ce poste là on voulait
probablement avoir une porte parole
qu'ils étaient capables de parler aux
québécois entre autres parce qu'on
savait que c'était un secteur où on
pouvait avoir une vulnérabilité en vue
des prochaines élections
si tous les détails ne sont pas sont à
table on doit maintenant quand même des
chiffres une façon de rassurer les
producteurs et un porte parole pour
expliquer le tout entre les réactions
sont positives
de la même façon les municipalités je
pense je n'ai pu entendre un peu plus
les gens étaient plutôt satisfaits de de
ce qui s'en vient donc on a voulu
apaiser les patrice si vous permettez
on parle de 2 milliards pour les
municipalités c'est pour l'ensemble du
canada
oui il ya beaucoup nice qualité à ce
qu'enfin qu'il ya une ouverture de ce
côté la chambre parentale il faudra voir
boxer avec le budget du québec dans deux
jours si le l'attribution d'un point de
tvq ça se concrétisera parce que ça
évidemment ici ça aiderait beaucoup et
pour ce qui est du budget fédéral
oui c'est une bonne idée d'en attribuer
par rapport à tous les milliards qu'on
entend et qu'on espère voir un bébé
ligne bleue tramway puisque vous voulez
2 milliards c'est bien et là ça va payer
dans les ca fait ça peut faire une
différence
il va y avoir le torride québec où là on
cherchait une enveloppe parce que le fn
prend beaucoup de l'envelope transports
les ferralais ballet piger dans une
autre enveloppe peut-être que ce 2
milliards là ici et là va apaiser des
chicanes qui rêve faire beaucoup de
bruit espérons en avoir
réaction chef du npd comme icône si nous
analysons la vie un canadien des gens
qui ont des jeunes familles qui ont un
enfant vont continuer de dépenser
jusqu'à 25000 dollars par année pour les
soins pour les garderies
parce qu'il n'y a pas de soutien pour
ces gens là c'est le petit montant qui
leur aide mais ne fait rien pour 25000
dollars de coût quand quelqu'un est
pluvieux veut acheter une maison
le gouvernement n'a rien n'à budget pour
construire des logements abordables rien
pour aborder les coopératives non il
offre liée aux gens d'utiliser le real
pour acheter leur maison
combien de millénium sont en mesure en
fait on même derrière cela montre à quel
point me trudeau est déconnecté de la
vie canadienne et ensuite quelqu'un doit
être recyclé
par exemple pour un nouveau métier et il
n'y a rien là d'un beau coup de milenio
n'ont pas d'emploi vraiment solide
il sait des contractuels ils ont des
emplois précaires et ce budget devait
justement parlé de la nouvelle formation
et ya rien pour les millions en poche tu
prêt car quand on est un peu plus âgée
on va voir des médicaments dans sa vie
il n'y a rien pour mettre en place une
couverture de médicament universel pour
tous les canadiens
on dirait que ce gouvernement a cédé à
la pression des grandes pharmaceutiques
et n'a pas apporté les changements qui
aurait réduit le coût des médicaments
finalement quand elle quelqu'un veut
prendre sa retraite le gouvernement ne
fait rien pour fermer les lacunes dans
les lois actuelles qui ont permis aux
compagnies de voler des fonds de pension
la situation avec 6 par exemple aux 700
millions de dollars de fonds de pension
ont été volés ça n'a pas été corrigée
dans le budget sur la plaie de fait le
nouveau tout au long de la vie d'un
canadien d'une canadienne
la vie n'est pas améliorée beaucoup de
gens vont continuer à bordeaux
mal et on a vu 14 milliards pour les
plus riches dans l'énoncé économique de
l'automne donc il n'y a rien pour fermer
ces échappatoires pour les options de
d'action des dirigeants des grandes
entreprises
alors il n'y a plus rien pour les gens
normaux quand le gouvernement déjà tous
distribués aux riches garderie c'est
tout juste ça va toujours que c'est
toujours le coup qui est presque vingt
cinq mille dollars pour quelqu'un pour
avoir ses services de garderie si on
parle le premier fois quelqu'un veut
acheter une maison
il dit que ont pu utiliser le gouvernant
libera dit qu'on va utiliser des
arrières combien des milléniaux combien
des gens qui achètent maison pour la
première fois ont assez d'argent dans
les arts et arts pour acheter une maison
puis pour la science médicaments les
familles vont continuer de paix pour les
médicaments parce que ça coûte trop cher
et c'est clair que ce groupe on a donné
un grand cadeau comme l'industrie
pharmaceutique
on n'a pas mettre mettre en oeuvre un
système de la science médicaments public
universel compréhensive et finalement si
on parlera d'entraînement les
entraînements pour monsieur madame qui
ont besoin d'entraînement un nouveau
c'est clair encore les gens qui ont des
emplois précaires qui ne peut pas
utiliser cette programme est finalement
tous les gens qui prennent leur retraite
il n'y a aucune mesure dans se bouger
pour a raté la baisse des pensions
quelque chose qui a qui se passait avec
les pensionnaires de style donc toujours
on voit un gouvernement qui continue de
donner des cons cadeaux aux entreprises
aux plus riches mais des miettes pour
monsieur madame tout le monde
voilà jack médecine qui n'est absolument
pas satisfait et rappelle que ces
mesures-là assurance médicaments aide
pour les millénium pour l'achat d'une
propriété c'est des mesures que le npd
veut et va proposer aux canadiens lors
de la prochaine campagne électorale
alors c'est comme si michel c'est rené
vézina lui voyez un peu le tapis lui
glisser sous les pieds là michel c'est
très clair bon il reste une chose que le
npd veut sa construction de logements
sociaux et soyons forts fera campagne là
dessus mais surtout je suis ça vraiment
sa signature
un politique jusqu'à maintenant c'est
vraiment le logement est bon le fait
qu'on va aider les milenio acheter des
maisons c'est bien mais en même temps
comment on est le disais tout à l'heure
comme d'autres collègues l'ont dit parmi
les gnocchis à 35 milles à l'heure dans
un reér alors c'est une mesure qui est
intéressante mais qu'il les peaux taxes
restent l'adresser à chelles il reste à
partir c est celle qui est inquiet plus
intéressante mais encore l'offre encore
faut-il avoir le content pour acheter la
maison c'est d'habitude pour on achète
sa première maison c'est ça qui est
vraiment le problème alors il va falloir
maintenant quand même celui-ci ne donne
un programme sur le logement social
parce que c'est vraiment là où il ya une
ouverture oui on est un petit mot oui je
voudrais simplement un élément dont on
n'a pas parlé qui est significatif parce
que c'est une somme quand même imposante
on attribue 3 milliards 250 millions
pour l'ensemble des services destinés
aux autochtones pour les premières
nations pour les questions de qualité de
l'eau et on sait à quel point c'est
réalisé c'est déplorable dans bien les
endroits au canada pour le soin aux
enfants l'éducation et d'autres mesures
de soutien
ça c'est une belle somme je comprends
que cela n'affecte pas et c'est pas pour
monsieur tout le monde
mais là il ya vraiment exercice ça n'est
sûrement pas clientéliste mais je pense
que là il ya vraiment une mesure qu'il
faut saluer parce qu'elle quelque part
là il ya des gens qui vivent dans le
quart monde au canada
c'est absolument intolérable pour le
reste on verra si ces mesures qu'on sont
un peu et patins éparpillés mais qui
vise des groupes précis pourront se
réaliser
il ya beaucoup de si la d'un mois
internet jusqu'en 2030 le conduisait à
trouver ça que ça peut pas vraiment ça
c'est urgent dans bien des parle bien
des communautés
c'est la différence entre le
dépeuplement la dévitalisation et dans
bien des endroits à travers le canada et
le fait de participer pleinement à
l'économie du 21e siècle c'est urgent
tracé avec moi pour rester avec nous on
a une nouvelle de dernière heure une
alerte en verre mesdames et messieurs
qui a été lancée en ontario la police de
la ville de markham c'est tout près
toronto ça est à la recherche d'une
fillette de 5 ans jannah jafri qui
aurait été enlevé par son père soloman
jafri à l'école armada alors qu'il n'ya
pas qu'il n'a pas le père la garde de
l'enfant
il aurait quitté les lieux en taxi la
jeune fille porte un chandail rose et
des leggings il y à une licorne sur son
sac à dos son père est âgé de 25 ans il
portemanteau bleus ça c'est le père que
vous voyez si vous avez des informations
vous communiquer avec la police
régionale de peel dont le numéro
apparaît à l'écran un 8c six bons
j'excuse et moi mesdames et messieurs on
va remettre la photo pendant que on la
remettra après promis on va coûter
monsieur singh 41 milliards de dollars
de nouvelles dépenses financées par des
hausses d'impôts s'il est réélu
c'est le camouflage la plus chère de
l'histoire des camouflages ce sont des
déficits budgétaires pour cacher le
scandale avant l'élection et des hausses
d'impôts pour les p après les élections
le scandale de corruption est
complètement consumé le grand vin de
chez trudeau depuis six semaines et
maintenant le menu des finances a
présenté un budget comme si c'était tout
à fait normal mais ce n'est pas normal
achetés sont normales et on ne peut pas
rester là les bras croisés pendant que
les libéraux font semblant de du
contraire justin trudeau a essayé
d'arrêter la poursuite criminelle d'une
compagnie qui était partisan des
libéraux en ut mineur son procureur
général jolie rousse très beau pour
qu'elle change sa décision quand elles
n'étaient pas d'accord il a compté
depuis il l'a bâillonnée il veut pas là
permettre de dire aux canadiens ce
qu'elle sait à ce propos n'avaient plus
tôt aujourd'hui
il a fermé la seule enquête publique sur
ce scandale de corruption
ils disent que la dissimulation est
souvent plus grave que le crémier mais
juste être doit cru que le contraire
était vrai il n'ya rien de pire que
cette situation monsieur trudeau a perdu
deux de ses ministres
seniors par des missions son meilleur
ami et conseiller principal a dû
remettre sa décision dans les
spectateurs de la première chaîne nous
vous disons au revoir nous allons
poursuivre notre couverture de ce budget
sur rd18 6 8 7 6 5 4 2 3 pour cette
alerte ambert jannah j'appliquerai été
enlevée par son papa donc à markham en
ontario
merci beaucoup de votre attention et
pour les eaux nous poursuivons cette
couverture avec toutes les réactions à
la prochaine
[Musique]